plus tarder donc poursuivre notre nos
auditions avec l'audition de monsieur le
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire dans le cadre
du budget
2024 nous avons un rythme très très
serré et très dense mais je crois
pouvoir dire que celui du ministre
aujourd'hui et tout aussi dense et
important puisque le ministre arrive à
l'instant du pas decalis où il était en
déplacement au côté du président de la
République donc on le on le remercie et
on va donc essayer de le ménager autant
que faire se peut mais il nous a déjà il
m'a déjà annoncé que voilà il doit
partir aux alentours de 19h20 donc
vraiment je pense qu'on arrivera à poser
l'entièreté des questions que vous
souhaitez poser à Monsieur le Ministre
donc la commission des Affaires
économique est particulièrement heureuse
bien sûr de vous entendre parce que nous
sommes à la veille d'une très riche
actualité pour le monde agricole y
compris législative vous nous donnerez
je l'espère quelques précisions que nous
attendons avec impatience je dois vous
faire part en préambule de la
circonspection grandissante que je
perçois chez plusieurs de mes collègues
quant au devenir du projet de loi
d'orientation et d'avenir agricole dont
le gouvernement parle depuis bientôt 2
ans mais qui de plus en plus a des
allures d'arlaisiennes un avant-projet
d'une vingtaine d'articles a circulé à
la rentrée mais l'on a appris depuis
lors que le volet au combien crucial sur
l'eau ne figurerait plus dans le projet
puis l'on a vu une proposition de loi
adoptée au Sénat sur les groupements
fonciers agricoles d'investissement
sujet qui devait être partie intégrante
de ce projet de loi d'orientation et
d'avenir agricole alors Monsieur le
Ministre pourriez-vous nous en dire plus
sur le champ et sur le calendrier de ce
texte qu'on annonce maintenant à la
rentrée
2024 à l'Assemblée nationale puis au
Sénat ne voyez pas dans ma question de
l'impatience mais voyez-y plutôt la très
grande motivation de l'ensemble de nos
collègues de tout bord dont je me fais
ici l'écho pour traiter de la question
du renouvellement des générations en
agriculture si stratégique pour notre
ferme France pour en venir à notre sujet
du jour à savoir le budget 2024 de
l'agriculture la presse spécialisée a
pointé justement l'absence de mesures
stratégiques et spéfique au projet de
loi d'orientation et d'avenir agricole
et plus généralement au renouvellement
des générations dans le PLF initial pas
suffisamment prête semble-t-il pour y
figurer à l'Assemblée un amendement du
Gouvernement reconduit sous une forme
légèrement différente le fond de
garantie inaf initiative nationale pour
l'agriculture française visant cette
fois-ci jusqu'à 2 milliards d'euros de
prêt des banques notamment pour
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
j'aurais quelques questions sur ce sujet
Comment ce dispositif s'articulera-t-il
avec les fonds similaire mise en place
dans au moins quatre régions en lien
avec le Fond Européen d'Investissement
pourquoi ne pas avoir à nouveau mobilisé
le Fond Européen d'Investissement alors
que l'expérience précédente avait été
semble-t-il concluante et êtes-vous bien
certain que votre dispositif sera
compatible avec le régime général
d'exemption sur les aides d'État alors
que l'État apporte sa garantie à titre
gratuit et pourrait être appelé dans
l'hypothèse d'un défaut massif à
renflouer 25 % du total des prêts soit
jusqu'à 400 millions d'euros pour le
reste la mission agriculture
alimentation forêt et affaires rural est
en nette augmentation de 23 % en crédit
de paiement c'est demain que que notre
commission se prononcera sur le rapport
pour avis mais nos collègues rapporteurs
ont noté que 22 points sur ces 23 % sont
liés au seul crédit de la planification
écologique les informations ont manqué à
nos collègues rapporteurs sur
l'affectation précise de ces crédits
c'est pour eux un motif d'insatisfaction
par ailleurs plus que jamais d'autres
institutions que votre ministère ont
laissé leur empreunte dans ce budget le
secrétariat général à la planification
écologique avec une enveloppe avec cette
enveloppe supplémentaire le ministère
d'économie et des finances et nous
vouons d'en parler avec votre collègue
Bruno Lemire avec la réduction de
l'avantage fiscal sur le gazol non
routier négocié directement avec la
FNSEA le ministère de la transition
écologique avec la hausse de la
redevance pour pollution diffuse c'est
le signe que l'agriculture est traversé
par des enjeux stratégiques pour notre
pays nous demandons comment dans ce
contexte vous parvenez à faire votre
place et à faire entendre la voix
singulière du ministère de l'Agriculture
certains craignent que la rue de varen
ne soit progressivement cantonné à la
gestion de crise en laissant les
orientations stratégiques se décider à
matinon à Aby ou à l'hôtel de rocklore
si ce ne sont pas des spécialistes du
monde agricole qui conçoivent les
politiques agricoles le risque est fort
qu'elle ne soit pas adaptée enfin pour
terminer en ma qualité de sénatrice du
département des Alpes Maritimes je
voudrais vous céder la parole et vous
demander donc de réagir sur la question
de la prédation je suis dans un
département qui est l'un des plus
prédatés de France et qui est le plus
prédaté depuis 1992 qui a vu la
réapparition du loup sur notre
territoire national je voudrais savoir
Monsieur le Ministre ce que vous avez pu
obtenir en en interministériel dans le
cadre du prochain plan national Lou qui
va se mettre en application au 1er
janvier 2024 et que vous puissiez nous
dire queles sont nos marges de manœuvre
supplémentaires justement avant que ce
plan de loup ne prenne véritablement
effet il semble qu'à cette date toutes
les possibilités en matière de
prélèvement ne soient pas utilisé
comment l'expliquez-vous enfin
j'aimerais bien connaître la traduction
budgétaire de ce plan loup puisque je
constate qu'il est mentionné dans le
dossier de presse de votre ministère sur
ce budget quells sont nos marges de
manœuvre par exemple en terme
d'indemnisation en cas de perte directe
et j'insiste également en cas de perte
indirecte voilà monsieur le ministre je
vous cède la parole pour le temps que
vous souhaiterez donc nous consacrer
pour parler à la fois de votre budget
mais aussi de ces questions que j'ai pu
vous poser sur l'actualité législative
qui viendra après le budget 2024 et sur
la question de la prédation et de la
survie du pastoralisme et ensuite nous
ouvrirons les débats en donnant la
priorité à nos rapporteurs de pour avis
de la mission
agriculture merci beaucoup madame la
présidente madame la Présidente
messieurs les rapporteurs Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénateur d'abord vous
remercier de m'accueillir une nouvelle
fois devant votre commission et de
m'avoir invité à vous m'exprimer devant
vous pour présenter le budget du
ministère en 2024 je vais essayer de me
tenir aux grandes orientations et de
répondre aux quelques questions vous
m'avez posé pour laisser libre cours à
l'ensemble des questions que vous
souhaiteriez me poser sur ce budget
premier élément c'est un budget je le
dis je reviendrai sur la dernière
question que vous posiez ou
l'avantdernière question mais c'est un
budget qui donne à notre agriculture les
moyens de mener les transitions
nécessaires il y a besoin de mener des
transitions en agriculture qui sont
importantes des transitions économiques
des transitions
écologiques des transitions d'adaptation
au dérèglement climatiques et il me
semble que je crois que c'est nécessaire
y compris pour assumer notre capacité de
souveraineté que de garder des moyens de
production qui soi en adéquation avec
les transitions qu'on a besoin de faire
parce que je le pense je l'ai déjà dit
plusieurs fois y compris je crois devant
de votre commission une partie de la
transition
elle va permettre d'assurer la
souveraineté on voit bien comment un
certain nombre d'agriculteurs
d'agricultures sont parfois en situation
d'impasse compte tenu des grands
dérèglements climatiques ou parfois des
dérèglements climati économiques que
nous avons sous les yeux pour relever ce
défi ce sont donc 1,3 milliard d'euros
supplémentaires en autorisation
d'engagement qui seront mobilisés vous
avez raison principalement pour déployer
la démarche de planification écologique
mais la démarche de transition que je
crois nécessaire c'est un virage
important puisque ce sont près de 4
milliards sur 3 ans que nous allons
mobiliser dans cette perspective très
concrètement on rentrera sans doute tout
à l'heure dans les détails c'est ce plan
et cette mobilisation permettra sans
ordre protocolaire d'intérêt mais je le
dis de la replantation de 5000 50000 km
linéaires de es sur plusieurs années
d'ici 2030 dans le cadre du Pacte e qui
montrera le rôle essentiel et central de
not nos agriculteurs et l'intérêt qui
peut y avoir d'ailleurs dans la haie
dans la préservation de la biodiversité
la rétention d'on le la lutte parfois
contre les inondations deuxième élément
la lutte la poursuite du déploiement de
la stratégie nationale pour les
protéines végétales c'est un élément de
reconquête de souveraineté un élément
aussi de diversification des cultures
pour rendre notre agriculture moins
dépendante en protéines et en engrais
minéraux trisème point important de ce
budget un fond en faveur de la
souveraineté alimentaire et des
transitions qui permettra de valoriser
de développer la reconception de système
à l'échelle des filières et des
territoires on voit bien qu'il y a un
certain nombre de territoires qui sont
en difficulté en impasse en particulier
l au dérèglement climatique 4è élément
la stratégie de réduction des produits
phytosanitaires 250 millions d'euros qui
pour la première fois pose un CAD un
cadre de méthode visant à identifier les
impasses technique et investir dans la
recherche et l'innovation il y a ce
qu'on dit depuis une quinzaine d'années
sur les trajectoires ça date du Grenel
de l'environnement donc ça n'est pas
tout à fait nouveau reconnaissons-le euh
simplement après il faut se donner les
moyens de la trajectoire se se dire
aussi là où sont les impasses pour
essayer de trouver des solutions et se
dire parfois quand on trouve des
solutions et parfois quand en non trouve
pas mais en tout cas il faut chercher
des alternatives 5è élément puisque ça
relève du périmètre de ce ministère le
renouvellement forestier 250 millions
d'euros ainsi que le développement du
bois de construction 200 millions pour
la filière aval c'est un élément
important je sais que votre commission
et un certain nombre d'entre vous ils
sont particulièrement attachés je crois
qu'on a une trajectoire là aussi qui
permet de crédibiliser une démarche
vis-à-vis des forestiers c'est une
trajectoire que nous assumons parce
qu'elle permet d'être à notre
agriculture d'être plus résiliente vous
avez av raison on voit bien que la
succession de crise met en situation de
fragilité l'agriculture d'un point de
vue économique d'abord et fait queut on
a besoin de la rendre plus résiliante et
donc cette manière de de de faire fait
qu'on devrait rendre avec ces moyens-là
l'agriculture plus compétitive on
n'oublie pas non plus d'ailleurs les
enjeux immédiats de compétitivité dans
ce PLF je pense aux allagements de
fiscalité sur les entreprises agricoles
qui sont également prévus dans la
logique de compensation de la des
dispositions sur le GNR je pense aussi
je pense ainsi par par exemple au
relèvement du plafond de micro BA ou à
la provision octroyée à l'élevage bovvin
pour limiter l'imposition des éleveurs
je sais que c'est une préoccupation
constante de beaucoup d'entre vous du du
rapporteur du plomb en particulier mais
beaucoup d'entre vous je le sais le
financement de ces priorités politiques
lié à la planification porte le budget
qui vous est présenté à 7 milliards
d'euros ce qui est totalement inédit et
ce qui est une augmentation de 17
millions par rapport à 2023 le budget
2023 étant lui-même un budget en forte
augmentation en particulier parfois le
reproche qu'on m'avait fait l'an dernier
compr
principalement lié à l'assurance récolte
mais enfin on est on va voir
malheureusement dans les jours qui
viennent à quel point ce dispositif
d'assurance récolte peut être opérant et
utile pour un certain nombre
d'agriculteurs touchés par les grands
épisodes climatiques que nous
connaissons ce budget nous permet aussi
de disposer de moyens pour soutenir les
filières ici sans entrer dans le détail
je voudrais citer le déploiement de
l'assurance récolte qui se poursuit
évidemment avec l'accroissement
significatif du nombre d'assurés qui en
a test y compris en prairie et c'était
des craintes qui avaient pu être
exprimées malgré les craintes qui
avaient donc été exprimées sur certains
disposition c'est un outil de gestion du
risque c'est l'un des outils de gestion
du risque le système assurentiel est
l'un des outils de gestion du risque euh
dont l'importance pour protéger le
revenu agricole va être croissante et ce
budget le permettra le soutien à
l'agriculture biologique au-delà des
fonds de crise et d'urgence qui sont
déployés 10 millions supplémentaires qui
permettront de porter le fond avenir bio
à 18 millions et de financer des actions
de communication pour relancer la
consommation je il y a un sujet de crise
à gérer immédiatement mais il y a un
sujet de relance de la consommation on
sait très bien à quel point le sujet de
la crise du Bio et principalement un
sujet de baisse de
consommation ces crédits viendront
compléter le plan que j'ai annoncé l'an
dernier enfin cette année on est
toujours en 2023 à la fois les 60 + 10
millions d'euros d'aide à la crise plus
le soutien à la filière par la commande
publique de l'État au travers de
l'atteinte des objectifs desgalim trème
point le soutien à notre politique
forestière je sais là aussi qu'il s'agit
d'une attente forte au-delà de ce que
j'ai dit sur le renouvellement forestier
la filière aval comme je m'y étais
engagé les effectifs de l'ONF sont
préservés pour la deuxè année cons
exécutive des moyens supplémentaires
sont prévus pour la création de la
nouvelle mission d'intérêt général
relative à l'adaptation au changement
climatique et à la défense de la forêt
contre l'incendie j'ajoute que les
débats à l'Assemblée nationale qui se
poursuivront je l'imagine au Sénat ont
permis deux avancées l'augmentation du
budget d'Aid à la forêt à la défense de
la forêt contre l'incendie vous en savez
quelque chose dans le département que
vous connaissez le mieux et puis
l'augmentation des effectifs du CNPF
l'autre établissement public celui qui
gère les forêts privées pour porter la
hausse initiale de 5 ETP à 16 ETP
finalement afin de permettre à
l'établissement d'assumer les nouvelles
missions qui sont les siennes que la loi
lui confère notamment la loi d incendie
qui abaisse le seuil d'accès au plan
simple de gestion et qui fait que
beaucoup plus de surfac vont être
concerné que donc il faut que les CNPF
puissent y faire face ces mesures
viennent conforter le soutien apporté à
nos agriculteurs avec les aides de la
PAC don le calendrier de versement a été
tenu je le souligne elle également
prolonger le soutien de l'État au côté
de nos filières face aux crises qu'ils
ont connu on en sait quelque chose les
uns et les autres et je vais juste ça
signaler alors c'est pas dans le budget
mais c'est dans le projet de loi de
finance de gestion de fin de gestion qui
vient d'être présenté qui prévoit 825
millions d'euros d'ouverture de crédit
pour financer ces mesures je pense aux
mesures de distillation je pense aux
mesures d'arrachage je pense aux mesures
sur l'influence aviare je pense aux
mesures sur la vaccination les mesures
que j'ai évoqué sur la B ou des fonds
d'urgence qui ont été déployés pour
faire face aux différentes situations de
crise 825 millions d'euros ça n'est pas
une masse à faire dans un budget vous
vous en doutez la planif iation donc le
soutien aux filières je viens de les
évoquer mais aussi c'est la trème de ce
buudget la sécurité sanitaire de nos
aliments et la santé de nos élevages
auquel nous consacrerons 650 millions
cette année 100 millions d'augmentation
par rapport à 2023 deux priorités la
mise en place le la fin du déploiement
de la police unique en charge de la
sécurité sanitaire des aliments et puis
enfin l'égagement de l'État dans le
cadre de la campagne de vaccination
contre l'influenza avière que nous avons
démarré sur laquelle là aussi nous avons
essayé de tenir enfin nous avons pas
essayé de tenir des délais nous avons
avons tenu strictement les délais au
jour près de démarrage de la vaccination
je je terminerai en évoquant deux ou
trois sujets sur lesquels vous m'avez
interrogé madame la Présidente dans le
propos liminire d'abord je commence par
le le plan national sur le pastoralisme
et le loup qui ser qui va rentrer en
vigueur en 2024 alors je sais que je
suis dit quand il a été présenté de part
et d'autrre on a fait le reproche
d'aller trop loin ou pas assez bon alors
je sais ça veut pas forcément dire que
c'est un plan d'équili mais je voudrais
vous dire les avancées qui ont été
celles portées par le ministère à
lariculture ce n c'était plutôt porté
par le ministère de lariculture on va
dire les choses comme elles sont premier
élément la reconnaissance de non
protégeabilité d'un certain nombre de
troupeaux c'est notamment le cas dans un
certain nombre de front de colonisation
en Bourgogne franchecté vers le Massif
central où on sait qu'il y a des
troupeaux il y a des modes d'élevage qui
ne sont pas protégeables et on peut pas
demander à des éleveurs de protéger dans
ces conditionsl ce qui veut dire que ça
évite un certain nombre ça les ça les
exonère d'un certain nombre de mesures
de protection parce que factuellement
ils ne peuvent pas les mettre mais ça
les permet de rentrer dans les
dispositifs ça ça concerne des élevages
beauvin principalement des élevages quin
aussi et c'est des éléments sur lequels
nous continuons à travailler 2,5 million
d'euros sur an pour la recherche en
matière de solution innovantes de
protection des troupeaux alors on
connaît les solutions classiques he les
chiens de protection avec tous leurs
écueils toutes leurs difficultés je vais
revenir et puis les clôtures et les
bergers mais il y a peut-être d'autres
solutions sur lequel il faut pas
renoncer à chercher les choses troème
élément alors ça c'est une demande qui
récurrente la l'accélération de la
délivrance des autorisations tir en CAN
d'attaque la simplification des
protocoles de tir
le tir de défense tir de défense simple
tir de défense renforcé les tirs de
prélèvement enfin bref on a un
dispositif quand je m'y suis penché
c'est pas c'est pas le pérmètre du
ministère l'agriculture je dois vous
dire cette affaire du loup mais c'est
quand même le périmètre de l'élevage
donc je suis je me suis assez
frontalement collé si vous me permettez
cette expression la simplification donc
des procédures de tir avec le passage de
deux voir à trois tireurs la capacité
donnée aux éleveurs qui le souhaiteront
de pouir accéder au statut de louftier
ce qui leur permettra d'être dans des
conditions de tir qui soient plus
simplifié pour eux parce que je pense
que c'est un élément la prise en compte
des dommages indirects les avortements
ou les pertes génétiques euh al demander
l'enveloppe en fait c'est une enveloppe
il suffit c'est c'est pas une enveloppe
qui est fermée c'est le c'est les
indemnisations elle courent le temps
enfin le autant qu'il y a de besoin
d'indemnisation et dès lors qu'on
ouvrirait il y a il y a pas de plafond à
cette on la place c'est 5 ou 6 millions
d'euros sur le budget du ministère de la
transition écologique qui sont prélevés
sur les qui sont pris pour les
indemnisations évidemment si elles
augmentent le budget s'alignera en
conséquence c'est plutôt 40 millions
d'euros sur les des mesures de
protection je signale toujours je l'ai
déjà fait l'an dernier ici je crois
c'est pris sur le budget de la PAC donc
aussi un enjeu pour nous d'arriver à
limiter ce budget là parce que c'est
quand même des éléments très importants
dernier élément qui n'est pas des
moindes donc c'est un certain nombre de
mesures qui cumuler les unes avec les
autres sont sont importantes il y a deux
éléments complémentaires que je voudrais
ajouter c'est sans doute d'évolué en
terme de stratégie de prélèvement euh
nous avons 209 loups à prélever cette
année comp tenu de l'augmentation de la
population constatée on avait tendance à
faire un/e par mois je pense que le
sujet n'est pas tant là il faut prélever
au moment où il y a les attaques
c'est-à-dire si c'est tô en saison c'est
tô en saison si c'est plus tard c'est
plus tard et pas se dire il faut que je
finisse mes 4/1è les qure derniers mois
alors que finalement les attaques sont
moins nombreuses par que par nature les
animaux pour un certain nombre d'entre
eux sont rentrés on est aujourd'hui à
175 loups prélevés je je ne ménage pas
mes efforts pour que nous atteignions sa
que les préfets sont très attentifs
là-dessus oui oui et je suis très
attentif à l'attention des préfets si
vous permettez cette expression pour
faire en sorte que on atteignne le
l'effectif qui a été prévu je rappelle
que l'an dernier on aurait dû en
prélever 209 puisque le comptage final
nous a montré qu'on en avait plus que ce
qu'on avait imaginé donc ça c'est le
premier élément sur la question sur la
question du loup alors c'est et en
marchant qu'on essaiera de d'améliorer
les choses mais je crois qu'on a tous
les dispositifs et le dernier point
pardon peut-être le plus important à
terme même si c'est pas du très court
terme c'est le statut de l'espèce c'est
pour la première fois dans un plan lou
on a fait deux choses on n pas donné
d'objectif de
population ce qui était pas le cas de
des quatre ou CIN plans loup précédents
et deuxième élément on a ouvert pour la
première fois ce qui était pour certains
une boîte de pend d'or c'était la
question du statut de l'espèce pour une
raison simple si l'espèce est un niveau
génétique et démographique satisfaisant
il faut qu'on se POS la question du
statut de l'espèce je le dis
tranquillement très pacifiquement c'est
qu'une question de bon sens et
compréhension est dans des départements
que les vôtres vous en savez quelque
chose deuxème sujet vous avez évoqué le
pacte d'orientation pour le
renouvellement des générations pacte et
loi la loi il y a un peu de vous dites 2
ans la vérité le président de la
République l'avait évoqué ça a été
évoqué à terre de Gy on a fait un
travail je crois de qualité sur le
terrain pour faire exprimer un certain
nombre de besoins dans le cadre du PACT
dans le cadre de la loi le que nous
avons c'est bien le premier trimestre
2024 sur la loi ce qui n'empêche pas que
nous commencions à déployer un certain
nombre d'éléments du PACT de fait un
certain nombre d'éléments que vous avez
dans le budget qui vous est présenté il
relève du
pacte quand on on essaie d'avancer sur
la diversification l'autonomie protéique
c'est un élément du PACT quand on est on
développe le fond entrepreneur du
vivance c'est un élément du pacte qui
n'a pas besoin qui est un élément
budgétaire qui n'a pas forcément besoin
de la loi vous évoquez de sujets sur la
question les éléments sont pas encore
tranchés sur ce que au final sera le
texte sur la question foncière
évidemment on ne peut pas poser la
question du renouvellement des
générations sans que la question
foncière je rappelle que le le la
proposition de loi sur les GFI est une
initiative
sénatoriale ça n'obère pas que le
gouvernement puisse s'en saisir d'une
façon ou d'une autre sur ces questionsl
parce qu'évidemment la question foncière
est importante pas pour réinventer non
plus je le dis j'ai toujours dit que il
y en a plusieurs dans cette salle qui en
sont témoins je n'ai jamais dit que
cette loi serait une loi foncière ce
n'est pas l'objet parce qu'il y a déjà
des lois qui ont été votées il y en a
une qui a été votée assez récemment
alors je vois les yeux qui se lèvent de
certains on peut se poser la question
mais il faut laisser aussi fonctionner
les lois et je constate que selon les
territoires l'application de la loi est
pas de même degré est pas de même nature
et donc il y a aussi à faire fonctionner
les outils donc c'est la question qui
restera mais en tout cas on présentera
le pacte dans les semaines qui viennent
parce que c'est un élément le pacte
c'est pas des paroles en l'air c'est des
moyens budgétaires des éléments
réglementaires des y compris sur la
question de l'eau hein que vous évoquez
et et des éléments de stratégie de
planification territoriale qui
permettront de dire des choses concrètes
au-delà de la loi pour avoir été
ministre des Relations avec le Parlement
j'ai pas complètement changé d'avis sur
l'idée que quand c'est la loi il faut
faire la loi quand il y a pas besoin de
la loi il vaut mieux passer par d'autres
voies ça me paraît tout auant efficient
sur cet élément
euh il y a quelques éléments aussi dans
la partie budgétaire alors PLF SS ou
autre sur je l'ai dit fond de garantie
augmentation des moyens du cas d'art
aussi des plafon et puis le renforcement
du service de remplacement c'est un des
éléments qui était et qui est dès cette
année mis en uvre et c'est en
particulier sur les questions d'élevage
une question qui est très prignante on
sait à quel point les conditions de
travail sont un élément très important
et puis je voudrais finir pour pas comme
un clind vous disz où se détermine la
politique agricole qu'elle est rue de
varen encore que il me semble que
matigon soit aussi rue de varen
mais boulevard Saint-Germain c'était ça
plutôt la question
se détermine rue de varen et de là où
vous reconnaîtrez que le budget qui a le
plus augmenté c'est le budget agricole
et si c'est pas le ministre de
l'Agriculture qui s'en occupe personne
ne le fera à sa place sur la question de
l'eau c'est une bataille de tous les
jours que nous menons pour faire en
sorte qu'on puisse déployer les plans
les
territorialisations avancer s telle ou
telle retenue de substitution telle
qu'elle a été prévue alors vous dire que
il y a pas desvent contraire ça serait
ça serait inexact enfin vous avez plutôt
un ministre de l'Agriculture qui est
fait en sorte de à chaque décision
défend pied à pied l'agriculture ça
n'empêche pas que nous ayons besoin
c'est pas parce que quand vous disiez 99
% ou 90 % des augmentations de céit soit
consacré à la planification écologique
mais je le fais parce que je pense que
c'est dans l'intérêt des agriculteurs je
vois trop aujourd'hui d'agriculteurs qui
sont en situation d'impasse économique
climatique pour ne pas me dire si je ne
les engage pas moi dans la transition
écologique avec une volonté que ça
trouve son équilibre économique c'est
pas la transition écque ique en l'air
c'est la transition écologique qui
tienne économiquement la rampe sinon ça
sert à rien sinon on parle dans le vide
et donc je pense que c'est la
responsabilité du Ministère de
l'Agriculture de se ressaisir ou de se
saisir plus des sujets environnementaux
et de pas le laisser faire par d'autres
et pas de laisser porter par d'autres la
question de la planification sur les
sujets phyau il y a ceux qui disent il y
a qu' fa con il y a longtemps qu'il le
disent il y a des solutions alternatives
pu après on se met autour de la table on
regarde s'il y a des impasses on regarde
s'il y a des alternatives on regarde les
moyens dont ont besoin les agriculteurs
et donc c'est plutôt comme ça que
j'essaie de m'employer à faire les
choses et je trouve plutôt bon signe
qu'on se réintéresse à l'agriculture par
que c'est
peut-être un domaine qui a été un peu
laissé de côté pendant des années pour
pas dire des dizaines d'années et qu'on
se préoccupe de la souveraineté
alimentaire et de l'agriculture même si
parfois je on s'en préoccupe pas comme
j'aimerais qu'on s'en préoccupe enfin
après tout si ça suscite l'intérêt ça
permet en tout cas d'en parler et que
nous et que je et vous puissi en parler
plus régulièrement pour dire la question
de la souveraineté la question du
stockage carbone elle va passer par
l'agriculture et donc on a besoin
d'encourager les
agriculteurs merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre donc je vais laisser la parole
à nos trois rapporteur pour avis Laurent
Duplomb franc Menonville Jean-Claude
tissau et ensuite à notre rapporteur
spécial de la commission des finances à
Christian Klinger Laurent duplom oui
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je vous entends parler
d'impasse lié aux évolutions climatiques
il faut pas passer sous silence les
impasses qu'on s'est proprement imposé
par la problématique de la
surtransposition de certaines normes qui
aujourd'hui ont plus de conséquences
malheureusement que les évolutions du
climat actuellement ça pourra venir
peut-être différemment mais pour
l'instant c'est le cas je voudrais
aborder plusieurs points monsieur le
ministre si vous me le permettez le
premier concernant la planification
écologique de 1,3 milliards au-delà de
juger les
faits le fait qui me semble le plus
difficile à appréhender c'est que nous
avons eu besoin de rapporter sur un
budget correspondant à une dizaine de
lignes qui explique le montant d'un,3
milliards ce qui veut dire qu'à chaque
fois on est sur des centaines de
millions d'euros par des explications
exactes qui sont uniquement quelques
lignes ou quelques
phrases j'avoue franchement que quand on
est rapporteur du budget 1,3 milliard
d'euros à l'échelle quand même de la
France c'est pas négligeable et qu'il me
semble qu'il aurait été plus intéressant
d'avoir les objectifs les moyens qu'on
aide les attentes et les unités de
mesure qui permettrai de voir comment
avec cet argent et les objectifs qu'on
se fixe comment on les évalue donc je
trouve l'exercice un peu difficile pour
nous en sachant quand même que c'est une
très grosse progression comme vous
l'avez dit du budget de l'agriculture
sur l'avantage fiscal et le
GNR je me félicite de voir que
finalement les propositions qui ont été
retenues sont celles que nous avions
écrit dans notre proposition de loi
concernant la compétitivité puisque que
ce soit l'exonération des plus-values
l'évolution du MICR BA ou l'évolution de
la déduction pour épargne de précaution
c'est exactement ce que nous avions
prévu dans la PPL donc je m'en félicite
plutôt il nen reste pas moins vrai que
comme vous le savez cela ne va pas
s'appliquer de façon linéaire sur les
agriculteurs et que ceux qui vont voir
une baisse de l'exonération ne vont pas
avoir obligatoirement la compensation
par l'exonération fiscale d'une ou de de
ces trois mesures donc il faudra quand
même y veiller de façon à ce qu'on se
retrouve pas avec des agriculteurs qui
se trouvent maltraités
concernant par contre l'augmentation de
la redevance pour pollution
diffuse sans vouloir et loin de moi
vouloir remettre le le principe de la
redevance en cause il me semble
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas accepter
de façon arbitraire une augmentation de
20 % de cette redevance payée par les
agriculteurs le mont qui est versé par
les agriculteurs aujourd'hui est de 180
millions d'euros ce qui les ferait
monter avec ces 37 millions qui sont
rajoutés à 27 millions d'euros cette
redevance elle doit conduire à améliorer
le travail des agriculteurs dans la
réduction des phytosanitaire ce que nous
constatons c'est que cette redevance
n'est pas utilisée à cette finl pour une
partie elle peut l'être nous arrivons à
avoir 70 millions d'euros 71 pour être
précis qui passe par le plan écopyo sans
savoir véritablement quels en sont les
résultats concrets si ce n'est un qui
paraît faire l'unanimité sur
l'amélioration parce qu'elle a conduit
grosso modo à une diminution de 25 % du
volume des produits phytosanitaires les
faisant passer de 54000 tonnes à 42000
tonnes c'est la mesure ferme défi il me
semble qu'aujourd'hui après 15 ans
d'écophyo il faut qu'on change de
braquet et que pour changer de braquet
il faut qu'on arrête de se servir de cet
argent pour financer au final en très
grosse partie les agences de l'eau sur
d'autres politiques que celle de la
réduction des phytosanitaires si on veut
véritablement réduire cet objectif et
atteindre cet objectif de 50 % à mon
sens la solution c'est de vulgariser et
de mettre en avant les progrès que les
fermes écofyo engagent et peuvent
permettre de faire pour pour cela il
faut massifier les aides à
l'investissement on n'aura pas une
diminution du volume des produits
phytosanitaires avec des principes qui
datent d' y a plusieurs années on a
aujourd'hui la capacité d'avoir plus
d'intelligence embarquée plus de
capacité de pouvoir gérer ces problèmes
aujourd'hui on a du matériel qui
pourrait permettre de diminuer dans
certaines cultures 80 à 90 % du volume
de phyo utilisé c'est maintenant à
travers ce plan d' 1,3 milliards plus
les aides écophyo à travers les
redevances qu'il faut massifier cette
aide de façon à vulgariser ce qui s'est
passé pendant 15 ans en terme de
d'évolution de progrès certes améliorer
et faire avancer sur les alternatives
quand il y a une alternative moi je suis
pas favorable à utiliser du
phytosanitaire quand l'alternative
technique mécanique ou autre peut
permettre de ne pas en utiliser mais
lorsqu'on sait que par définition la
seule solution c'est de diminuer le
volume plutôt que d'interdire la
mollécule choisissons d'abord de
diminuer le volume en espérant trouver
les alternatives qui permettra peut-être
par la suite d'interdire la mollécule
plutôt que de faire exactement l'inverse
parce que sinon on est sur quelque chose
de totalement dogmatique un peu plus
vite donc en fait excuse-moi Dominique
alors je jeouis mais je j'ai presque
terminé donc en fait l'idée de cette
question là c'est est-ce que monsieur le
ministre sur ces sujets-l on ne pourrait
pas se reposer pour voir comment on
réorganise les financements comment on
réorganise les politiques liées à la
réduction des phytosanitaires de façon à
avoir avoir enfin des moyens qui
permettent d'avoir les objectifs et
d'avoir un système qui consiste au lieu
de stigmatiser les agriculteurs à
travailler ensemble et de les
accompagner parce qu'ils sont tous
favorables à la réduction des
phytosanitaires parce que pour tous
c'est un avantage économique merci
Laurent franc
Menonville merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre moi je vous
questionnerai sur deux
sujets premièrement revenir sur la
réduction donc de l'avantage fiscal sur
le GNR notamment nous avons eu
l'impression lors de lors de cette
discussion long d'un d'un certain
flottement avec autour du montant 70 90
millions d'euros d'ailleurs ce fut
également le cas au travers l'audition
de de de Bruno Lemer du ministre de
l'économie précédemment pouvez-vous donc
nous expliquer cet écart et surtout nous
rassurant en prenant l'engagement que
des ajustements seront effectués si le
constat s'éloigne des prévisions de la
loi de finance notamment par une loi de
finance rectificative pour compenser
donc équitablement no nos agriculteur
par ailleurs un complément de de
question concernant les biocarburants et
notamment le passage rapide au baant
vous paraît-il réaliste et raisonnable
ne ne faudrait-il pas privilégié dans un
premier temps donc des carburants
intermédiair et notamment le le B30
la deuxième le deuxème
questionnement s'agissant donc de la
réalisation d'un inventaire forestier
outre mer force de constater que le
gouvernement aujourd'hui prend la mesure
de l'enjeu car il en finance la
préfiguration avec 6 millions d'euros
parmi les 15 de la planification
écologique dédiée à la forêt outremer il
était temps puisque nous devons le on
peut le rappeler ça a été voté en 2014
dans la loi d'avenir reprécisé par
notamment par le Sénat dans la loi
climat résilience en 2021 seulement un
tel inventaire forestier prendra entre 4
et 5 années à être complété d'après
l'hygiène et l'ONF qui en seront les
maîtres d'œuvre or aucun des 24 TP
associé à cette hausse ne figure dans ce
budget est-ce que vous pourriez
peut-être nous le préciser autrement dit
nous craignons que cela renvoie cet
inventaire à des horizons plus lointains
et notamment aux environs 2030 pourquoi
ne pas accélérer cet outil dont nous n
aurions un besoin crucial au plus vite
surtout quand on sait l'enjeu de la
forêt guyanaise pourtant deux fois plus
réduite que la forêt hexagonale mais qui
stock le double de de carbone donc c'est
un enjeu à la fois écologique mais aussi
économique pour la valorisation de ce
projet de cette forêt moi je je
terminerai seulement mes propos
donc sur la partie renouvellement
forestier ce budget
donc maintient ses ses moyens et les
accentueent dans le temps le
renouvellement forestier est un enjeu
qui doit s'inscrire dans le temps long
et c'est ce que ce quiinitie ce ce
budget et et également le maintien de
des effectifs de l'ENF pour la 2e année
avec bien évidemment aussi le le bémol
de la de la de l'enjeu de redéploiement
de ces moyens au travers ces nouvelles
missions et il faut qu'on soit vraiment
vigilant à ce que c'est ce redéploiement
ne se fasse pas au détriment des
territoires merci Fran Jean-Claude Tiss
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre de manière globale une fois
n'est pas coutume nous pouvons
collectivement nous satisfaire de
l'augmentation des crédits accordés à
cette mission et de l'ajout de nouveau
et vous me faites perdre la ligne là et
de nouveau et de
l'ajout c'est tellement rare que après
les propos de Laurent Duplon qui
quasiment va nous rejoindre de ce
côtélà je suis perturbé de l'ajout de
nouveau dispositifs le P notamment mais
il est quand même de notre de dev voir
de législateur de de rappeler que cette
augmentation que vous avez abordé
d'ailleurs sur ce sujet est un peu en
trompeloil avec une reventilation des
crdit engagés des engagements pris sur
plusieurs années pour ma part je me suis
intéressé à la question du fond
entrepreneur du vivant annoncé il y a
près d'un an par le Président de la
République ce dernier avait doté ce fond
de 400 millions d'euros dans le but je
cite de porter dans les premières années
le foncier pour permettre de lisser la
charge pendant plusieurs années et
d'aider à mener les transformations
indispensables pour que la reprise soit
ainsi un moment
d'accélération fermé les guillemets plus
d'un an après ce fond reste pourtant
teinté de nombreux mystères et apparaît
surtout comme un conglomérat de mesures
disparates nous nous interrogeons en
particulier sur le montant de 400
millions d'euros qui nous a jamais
vraiment été détaillé et expliqué et sur
le rattachement de ce fond de ce fond
d'investissement à France 2030 censé
pourtant financer l'innovation de
rupture nous ne pouvons pas nous
empêcher de penser que l'imputation à
France 2030 vient palier en catastrophe
la sous-consommation de ce fond
apparemment seulement 17 % de à la
moitié de l'année de 2023 lié notamment
à mon avis à notre avis à la complexité
de l'attribution de ces crédits plus
inquiétant encore on comprend qu'en l'
absence d'une offre suffisamment mature
de fonds de portage du foncier il sera
en réalité difficile de consacrer plus
de 60 millions d'euros son environ 15 %
de ce fond à ce sujet alors que les
besoins en portage du foncier et des
capitaux sont considérables 12 millions
d'euros par an pendant 5 ans c'est moins
que ce qui consacre c'est moins que ce
qui consacre chaque année la banque des
territoire est-ce que vous nous
confirmez bien cet ordre de grandeur de
15 %. de manière très concrète à quoi
vont servir les 3450 millions restants
pouvez-vous nous en donner quelques
orientations et nous préciser le
calendrier pour ma part je considère que
ce fond doit être bâti et conçu pour
accompagner le monde agricole dans la
transition écologique avec un juste
équilibre à trouver entre
conditionnalité et efficacité enfin
monsieur le ministre je souhaitais vous
vous questionner sur les crédits
accordés aux mesures
agrienvironnementales et climatiques les
MAEC qui apparaissent particulièrement
sous-financé alors que la France est
l'État membre de l'Union européenne qui
all loue la plus faible part du second
pilier MAEC 22 % et ce sous-financement
met en grande difficulté les
agriculteurs qui ont pris les
engagements virtueux et les régions qui
sont contraintes de refuser les dossiers
pourtant éligibles monsieur le ministre
comptez-vous renforcer pardon
comptez-vous renforcer significativement
les moyens alloués au MAEC et un propos
aussi hors hors hors budget hors loi de
finan à propos de j'ai interpellé tout à
l'heure monsieur le ministre le maire à
propos de la tempête qu'on subit et je
sais que vous êtes allé sur place
monsieur le ministre mais il nous
faudrait à à à mon avis à notre avis une
aide d'urgence euh en désactivant les
minimis euh pour pouvoir faire face à la
situation très difficile que vivent nos
nos collègues éleveurs et nos collègues
maréchés essentiellement dans ce
territoire-là il faut une prise en
charge des cotisations MSA et donneré à
mon sens mais c'est un peu un peu un peu
rapide de tels propos mais aussi un
accès au chômage partiel parce que ce
sont des toutes enfin beaucoup il y a
beaucoup de de d'exploitations qui qui
embauchent qui sont euh euh qui
embauchent beaucoup de personnes dans le
mar ch donc voilà c'est une question
merci JeanClaude le rapporteur spécial
de la commission des finances Christian
Klinger et ensuite le ministre vous
répondra oui une très petite question
moi je réserve l'avis de la commission
des finances pour demain matin
une petite question pour monsieur le
ministre à vrai dire deux dont il a déjà
répondu partiellement dans le projet de
loi d'acte pacte et d'orientation
agricole il y a un certain nombre de
points qui sont en discussion et qui se
retrouvent dans dans ce projet de loi
lesquels vous avez déjà dit
partiellement vous av déjà parciellement
répondu et à contrario quels sont les
points qui sont en discussion et qui se
retrouvent pas dans le projet de loi et
qui nécessiterait peut-être un projet de
loi 2024
rectificatif monsieur le ministre pour
répondre à nos
collègues vous me posez une colle sur la
dernière
question j'avais pas imaginé une
question qui me disent qu'est-ce qu'il y
a pas qui aurait pu avoir je vais
réfléchir pour la du
coup je ser mais oui oui je il me semble
que sur un certain nombre de points il
me semble que on essaie d'abord on a les
crédit habituel du ministère de
l'Agriculture les trajectoires qui ont
été fixées je pense à l'assurance
récolte et à ce qu'on fait au travers de
la planification après ce qu'on sait pas
c'est les aléas que quand vous voyez ce
qu'on a par exemple en fin de gestion
là c'est les crises ou les aléas qui
peuvent arriver personne l'a encore
évoqué par exemple la crise de la MHE
est une crise qui qui qui qui est très
en vigilance pour nous ministère
deagriculture parce que c'est une
nouvelle crise sanitaire dont on se
serait bien passé et qui peut avoir des
effets de dstructuration économique très
puissant très puissant les effets oui
euh donc ça pour le coup c'est des
éléments de vigilance sur lequel nous
sommes après on peut toujours dire qu'on
aurait pu faire ça ou plus faire ça mais
il me semble que là nous avons les
éléments de réponse à ce que peuvent
être
les les nécessités me semble-t-il de
transition après il y a ce qu'on sait là
etce qu' malheureusement parce que c'est
souvent plutôt des crises qu'on a géré
on doit être appelé à à faire et et sur
la MHE je dis au passage je pense qu'on
a bien évré sur les marchés italiens
espagnol puisqu'on a libéré ce qui ne
s'est jamais fait en 10 jours on a
ouvert les frontières en 10 jours ce qui
était franchement un défi que j'avais un
peu donné à mes équipes mais qui était
quasiment impossible hein parce que
normalement la règlementation nous
interdisait totalement d'exporter ces
produits c'est jeune bovvin et si on
avait pas pu le faire on aurait eu
assisté à une chute des cours qui était
absolument dramatique euh deuxième
élément regarde sur les questions
sanitaires parce que là normalement la
pression devrait baisser j'en parle
parce que c'est un moment il faut quand
même en parler devant vous euh la
pression devrait baisser la contenu de
ce qui est l'arrivée de l'automne et de
l'hiver donc de la température il faut
qu'on se prépare au printemps donc il y
a un travail européen pour qu'on
dérèglemente sur cette maladie et
deuxième élément comment on va
indemniser là on a des sujets par
exemple sur lequel je n'ai pas d'élément
à vous donner aujourd'hui puisque c'est
la perte d'un animal les pertes induites
é vendimement d'un animal pendant des
mois on sait pas ce qu'il va pouvoir
donner et puis les surcous vétérinaires
par exemple là-dessus on travaille et ça
n'est pas dans le projet de loi de
finance tel qu'il est vous proposé mais
en transparence je vous le dis pour les
autres points monsieur le sénateur duup
plom d'abord vous avez
raison faut veiller à ce que on regarde
ce que ce que nous avons produit
collectivement alors j'essaie de ne pas
vous embarquer dans la patrouille mais
que nous avons produit collectivement
depuis 15 ou 20 ans en terme de de
succession de normes ou de surnormes et
moi je dis à chaque fois qu'on me pose
la question de rajouter une norme je dis
Europe ou rien parce que sinon d'abord
on a on est incapable de discuter au
niveau européen de clauses miroir si
c'est des règles qu'on s'est fixé tout
seul parce que le sujet c'est d'abord
d'avoir des règles ensemble et après de
dire bah on veut les mêmes quand les
Australiens les néozélandais les
Brésiliens sinon nous on va voir nos
petits camarades les 26 autres on le dit
on a fait une norme EN FRANCE et donc il
faut que vous imposiez des clauses
miroir les autres vous regardent et vous
disent mais c'est sympathique mais nous
navons pas produit cette norme en
Allemagne en Espagne en Italie prod
après j' j'essaie monsieur le sénateur
ciper comm vous savez de ne pas en
rajouter et de freiner des cas de fer
dès quelqu'un me propose d'en rajouter
et ma défense c'est Europe rien d'autre
c'est le seul moyen de s'en tirer et
après pourrait se poser les questions
que vous posez et nous sommes d'accord
comme vous le savez pour dire et
maintenant on pourrait peut-être revenir
sur quelques sujets voà et on va être à
mon avis tenu dans d'y revenir contenu
en particulier d'ailleurs du des
questions de dérèglement climatique euh
sur les mesures fiscales vous avez
raison c'est ce que vous aviez évoqué
dans le projet de loi que nous avions
débattu ici au Sénat je suis d'accord
avec vous et donc je le dis ici il faut
qu'on travaille ensemble je le dis sous
l'œil des rapporteurs je pense que c'est
70 à 80 millions c'est pour ça que mais
c'est on a basé les compensations sur
80 on est plutôt sur 70 à priorie mais
par sécurité on est plutôt sur la base
de 80 deuxème élément je suis d'accord
avec vous je l'avais exprimé moi
d'ailleurs et compris auprès des des
équipes de B il faut faire attention à
ce que ça redescende quand
même chez tous ceux qui voit leur
avantage fiscal réduit or il y a sans
doute encore des éléments des trous dans
la raquette je pense que en particulier
en secteur d'élevage on a des questions
qui se posent et donc moi je suis ouvert
et nous continuons à travailler avec mes
équipes et avec Bercy pour regarder ce
que pourrait être des ajustement dans
les trois mesures fiscales qui
permettraient de mieux intégrer des
secteurs qui pourrai être plus pénalisés
que l'autrre par cette cette baisse de
l'avantage fiscal et qui serait pas
compensé de façon assez alors linéaire
c'est jamais linéaire vous savez comme
moi mais en tout cas
trop déséquilibré et c'est plutôt
élevage grande culture la frire on va se
dire les choses comme elles sont et donc
on travaille là-dessus moi j'avais
j'avais alerté dès le début j'avais dit
attention on risque d'avoir un
redéploiement des 70 millions
territorialement qui soit pas et comme
c'est quand même une trajectoire qu'on
essaie de donner sur cette question de
des fis que GNR faut quand même qu'on
soit qu'on s'assure que ça ça la
compensation se fait bien
géographiquement et donc par filière de
manière aussi homogène que possible 3ème
élément que vous avez évoqué c'est
redevance pollution des VUS et puis le
grand paquet fiscalité haut et haut euh
alors d'abord dire qu'une partie des une
grande partie des crédits puisqueil y a
145 millions sur les 400 et quelques
millions qui sont mis dans le plan haut
qui vont aller à l'agriculture donc en
en net et après je je vais je vais je
vais faire le bémol mais en net c'est
moin des moyens en plus pour les
questions d'eau pour l'agriculture c'est
les phyos mais c'est pas que les phyos
c'est la réduction la sobriété
c'està-dire les équipements les ouvrages
il me semble que c'est important d'y
revenir de de dire cette chose là parce
que c'est c'est un élément qui qui
compte pour moi de façon très importante
après nous avons un sujet je suis
d'accord avec vous c'est qu'on fasse en
sorte que les crédits qui sont prélevés
sur l'agriculture retourne bien à des
projets agricoles donc c'est le dialogue
que j'ai engagé avec le ministère de la
transition écologique et avec les
agences de l'eau je les ai réunis la
semaine dernière pour leur dire ces
moyens là ils doivent aller à
l'agriculture ils doivent aider au
trajectoires que vous donnez à
l'agriculture sinon alors il y a des
moyens qui sont donnés quand même mais
je suis assez pr à penser qu'il faut que
nous allions nous d'ailleurs au
ministère regarder et avec avec la
profession agcole et avec les
parlementaires que vous êtes regardez si
les crédits qui sont déployés sont bien
déployés en direction des objectifs que
nous nous assignons parce que sinon nous
aurions je le sais une une difficulté et
ça c'est un élément important j'ajoute
qu'une partie des crédits fléchés dans
le plan haut ils sont fléchés j'yveillé
personnellement pour les raisons que je
viens d'évoquer façon subreptis ils sont
fléchés ministère de l'Agriculture le
fond hydraulique e c'est un fond
ministère de l'Agriculture parce que
parfois ça part quelqu sans faire de
mauvais jeux de mot dans la cuyauterie
on faudrait faire du génie rural pour
voir le où est parti le bleu vous voyez
ce que je veux dire qu'on a mis dans
l'eau le colorant parce qu'il faut qu'on
arrive bien à l'objectif qu'on soit
assigné donc on a besoin de ces
élémentsl ça viendra aussi d'ailleurs
ces ces fondsl revaloriser les MAEC donc
on a besoin de rentrer en dialogue ce
que j'ai fait là récemment avec les
comités de bassin les agences de l'eau
pour leur dire voilà la trajectoire phyo
voilà la trajectoire sobriété est-ce
qu'on est-ce que les mesures que vous
proposez vont bien dans ce sens là sinon
il va y avoir très rapidement on est
déjà d'ailleurs dedans pour être très
honnête une incompréhension du monde
agricole qui va vous dire vous prélevez
et ça va pas chez nous ou ça va pas dans
les mesures qui nous permettraient
d'atteindre les objectifs qui sont vous
avvez demandé enfin et je je termine
pardon je suis un peu long mais c'est
des sujets de changer de braquet sur la
question phyo je je reconnais que étant
arrivé au poste depuis 18 mois j'ai
assez vite remarqué que on avait fait
beaucoup de déclaratif depuis des
dizaines d'années enfin depuis deis de
Grenelle de l'environnement la vérité
c'est là que ça démarre et que au fond
on n'avait pas mis les moyens ni la
stratégie et donc ce qu'on est en train
de faire là avec les f filière on
appelle les task force ça fait chic sans
doute d'employer ce terme mais c'est de
dire on regarde filière par
filière usage par usage quelles sont les
situations des molécules aujourd'hui
quels sont les risques qu'on a sur les
molécules alors parfois avec une crainte
du milieu agricole de dire vous avez
identifié 75 molécules c'est les 75 que
vous voulez interdire non c'est pas pour
les interdire c'est juste pour se dire
on sait qu'on a un processus de
réhomologation européen et que dès qu'il
y a un processus qui est en cours il y a
des évaluations et l'évaluation porte le
risque qu'on dit interdiction ou pas
interdiction donc on fait un travail
usage filière pour regarder les impasses
on aura à à continuer à déployer
d'ailleurs dans ce registre là ce qu'on
a fait sur la betterave pour essayer de
d'aboutir à des solutions qui viendront
principalement sans doute de la semence
mais peut-être des pratiques je de même
qu'on va mettre des moyens sur la
question de la sererise parce que c'est
quand même désespérant que depuis 10 ans
on soit en impasse de ce point de vue-là
il faut qu'on fasse un pnri de même
nature pour moi sur des filières comme
celle-là où on a des impasses techniques
redoutables qui font à la fin ça
produira plus
donc comment et sur la l ver du et sur
la je ne l'avais pas tout à fait dans le
scope mais je suis prêt à en parler avec
vous mais on a un peu parlé j'ai aussi
les andiv enfin bref chaque jour un
bonheur pour moi comme pour vous mais
vous avez raison c'est il faut qu'on
dise à chaque fois où est-ce qu'elle
impasse et parfois c'est pas d'énormes
moyens qu'il faut pour des des cultures
ce qu'on appelle les âges mineurs alors
c'est mineur mais c'est pas mineur pour
les agriculteurs qui sont concernés et
donc faut qu'on anticipe ça et troisème
élément
ça ce n'est pas que dans les moyens RPD
les 250 millions d'euros sur phito euh
c'est des moyens qui sont mis pour la
recherche et aussi pour les équipements
parce que je je suis complètement
d'accord avec vous plutôt que de dire
c'est blanc ou noir interdit autorisé on
est capable sur un certain nombre de
produits avec des buses antidérives avec
des buses qui limitent avec un
traitement comme vous l'avez dit avec du
du matériel très sophistiqué de réduire
les doses et dès lors qu'on réduisit
j'étais l'autre jour un salon
l'innovation en he et Loir sur ces
questions là on peut réduire parfois de
50 à 70 %
simplement par non vous avez raison
Madame la Présidente c'est pas tout à
fait nouveau simplement ce qui est
peut-être nouveau alors en tout cas je
porte cet espoir là vous savez quand on
est ministre on a toujours l'espoir
qu'on va changer un peu des choses je
porte l'espoir que les moyens qu'on met
là ils vont permettre de mettre tout le
monde au pied du mur et de dire
maintenant on met les moyens et on y va
et on prend les filières les unes après
les autres il me semble que c'est un
élément très important qu'il faut qu'il
faut qu'il faut évoquer monsieur mon je
crois que j'ai répondu sur la question
de la
filière du GNR pardon de l'enveloppe qui
était enfin le du du chiffrage qui était
avancé sur la question on est en train
d'affiner sur l'inventaire forestier il
y a une part de moyens mais j'essaierai
de vous répondre pour la séance sur les
moyens qui seront fléchés à terme pour
faire en sorte qu'on essaie d'avancer
alors c'est vrai que c'est 4 5 ans
j'aurais préféré qu'on le fasse il y a
15 ans on le fait il est jamais trop
tard pour bien faire comme disait
l'autre mais on va regarder je vous
répondrai sur la question des moyens à
ce moment-là parce qu'on est en train
d'affiner avec le ministère des
outresmèes avec les l' équipe de lonf
qus sont les moyens humains qu'il faudra
mais les moyens seront
faits là-dessus sur le renouvellement
forestier je sais plus la question que
vous aviez mais cé pas une question
c'est pour le
saluer oui alors c'était la volonté je
je suis de ceux qui regrette la fin du
fond forestier national c'était en 99 ça
a été une erreur tragique parce qu'on a
tué les filières de pépiniristes on a
tué la dynamique forestière de
renouvellement forestier ça a duré 20
ans et c'est 20 ans d'inertie forestière
tandis que pendant ce temps là le puit
forestier le dérèglement climatique
faisait son œuvre je pense ça a été une
erreur tragique en 99 ou 2000 d'arrêter
le fond forestier on a cru que c'était
ringare en fait on réhabilite a des
moyens beaucoup plus importants la
trajectoire que je vous donne c'est une
trajectoire pluriannuelle j'ai besoin
d'ailleurs dans cette trajectoire
pourelle de conforter les les pépinières
on va buter très vite sur pépinière et
graines donc il faut que je
développe des pépinières publiques et
privé des graines publiques et privées
avec en plus une ressource qui va
s'appauvrir cont tenu du dérèglement
climatiquereise de travau et la question
des entreprises de travaux fesers avec
la question de la main d'œuvre enfin
bref
je madame la Présidente mettez pas tout
à chaque fois mais oui en tout cas on
est sur une trajectoire qui qui est
importante alors tant que je tiens me
féliciter je je félicite le sénateur
tisso
de d'avoir tenté de dire que c'était pas
si
mal mais néanmoins virgule alors d'abord
pour répondre à la troire la trajectoire
que je vous donne 1 milliard 3 c'est une
trajectoire sur TR fois 1 milliard 3
deuxième élément comme j'essaie d'être
un garçon honnête je vous recycle pas
des crédits qui étaient
ailleurs c'est c'est net budgétaire
c'est des éléments supplémentaires et à
la fin de l'année 2024 vous pourrez
juger que c'est des moyens
supplémentaires parce qu'on a besoin de
ça pour la transition et compris pour
crédibiliser notre démarche vis-à-vis
des agriculteurs je veux pas retourner
devant les agriculteurs en disant il y a
des efforts à Fort de transition et en
fait je vous recycle les choses c'est
tout à fait délié d'autres dispositifs
je pense à entrepreneur du vivant ça
n'est pas du tout dans ces crédits
budgétaires les 400 millions
d'entrepreneurs du vivant ne sont pas
dans ces crédits là c'est un élément qui
est dans France 2030 vous l'avez signalé
euh pardon de vous dire que le le fond
n'est pas encore alors là vous pourvez
me faire un grief de de dél le fond
n'est pas encore à l'œuvre il va se
déployer là avec en particulier un
certain nombre de d'établissements
public foncier je pense au Safire mais
pas qu'au Safire pour faire en sorte
qu'on adosse en première année c'est
c'est 100 millions d'euros qui seront
mis et puis après au fur et à mesure on
a on va jusqu'à 400 euh mais là on a je
reconnais volontiers que on a besoin
d'affiner les dispositifs parce que
c'est un dispositif un peu un peu
complexe et dans le déploiement du PACT
évidemment ces éléments là seront seront
seront redonnés il me semble que c'est
un élément important sur la question des
Mees
euh alors d'abord les moyens budgétaires
de l'État sont de 5 millions de plus que
ce qu'ils étaient dans la période
précédente donc on a pas réduit les
enveloppes de Me ce qui est nouveau
c'est qu'il y a une demande très
supplémentaire deuxième élément je le
dis ça n'est pas un enfin on peut pas je
le dis en responsabilité budgétaire avec
le budget que j'ai je peux le dire de
façon plus plus à l'aise si je peux dire
c'est pas une logique de guichet où on
s'arrête quand on a plus de dossier
enfin il y a un moment on a demandé à
aux régions de faire des
critérisations bon dans la région que je
connais bien la région Centre Val-de
Loire nous sommes quelques-uns autour de
dans cette salle j'ai pas de problème
d'enveloppe dans la région pays Deloire
j'ai pas de problème d'enveloppe bon
alors je fais de grillef à personne mais
il faut aussi que chacun fasse un peu de
de régulation budgétaire parce qu'il
suffit pas de me dire monsieur le
ministre il y a besoin de 500 millions
qu'est-ce que vous faites bah c'est un
peu compliqué alors néanmoins donc
l'état est au rendez-vous financièrement
deuxième élément on est en train de
valider puisqu'il y avait des moyens
budgétaires qui étaient prévus ça
rejoint ce qu'a dit le sénateur DUP Plon
d'ailleurs des moyens qui étaient prévus
par les agences de l'eau 70 millions
d'euros je ne les ai pas aujourd'hui sur
la table ça va commencer à répondre à la
demande on verra s'il y a des
redéploiements possibles on verra si
d'ailleurs dans le plan ha il y avait 50
million d'euros de ma c'est prévu en
plus donc ça viendra aussi en plus
ajouter vous voyez ce que je veux dire
donc on est déjà à une centaine de
millions qui permettrait de répondre à
un certain nombre de besoins mais ça
n'est pas un guichet ouvert sans limite
sinon je je je trouve queon n'est pas
rigoureux d'un point de vue budgétaire
je répète l'État a été au rendez-vous je
suis très convaincu des MAEC pour les
avoir si je peux dire dans un temps où
j'étais dans d'autres fonctions et dans
d'autres structures pratiqué donc je
suis très convaincu de l'intérêt que ça
dans la l'accompagnement de la
transition mais de toute façon d'ors et
déjà on sait rien quand vous disant ça
qu'on va avoir doublé augmenter de 30 à
40 % l'enveloppe des Mike bon donc mais
c'est pas c'est les les arm monent pas
jusqu'au ciel si vous me permettez cette
expression donc on a besoin de faire de
la régulation on a besoin aussi de dire
aux éécuteurs vous vous êtes engagé vous
êtes pas engagé pour rien dernier
élément comment on continue
l'instruction il y a ceux qui ont donné
des intentions au mois d'avril ou au
mois de mai à la déclaration PAC on va
regarder si les intentions se
transforment en réalité voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est souvent un peu moins que
les intentions donc ça permettra de
regarder les moyens budgétaires puis
comme vous vous savez les enveloppes
peuvent être un peu fongibles à
l'intérieur des piliers de la PAC à
l'intérieur des piliers ben on regardera
s'il y a des des moyens de de de de
mettre de la fongibilité là où il y
aurait de la la sous-consommation de
crédit dernier point pour la tempête
alors c'est un peu compliqué je vais
essayer de vous la faire simple
euh il y a les pertes de fonds il y a
les pertes de récolte les pertes de
récolte c'est le système assuranciel que
vous avez voté ici auocénat vous êtes
assuré vous êtes prenez
l'assurance tout va bien moyenant les 20
% de de France comment oui absolument
ensuite on a un sujet c'est euh c'est
ceux qui vont bénéficier ce qu'on
appelle le 3e étage ISN alors c'est le
moment du déclenchement c'estàdire que
certains sur certaines cultures par
exemple sur les fraises je vous donne un
exemple sur les fraises vous avez
plusieurs récoltes dans l'année euh ceux
qui ont perdu alors en Bretagne ils
avaient fini de produire les fraises
mais quand sur sur l'atelier de perte de
récolte vous avez pas de perte sauf
queils vont perdre sans doute en récolte
pour l'année qui vient alors non mais
j'essaie de décrire un problème donc ils
atteindront pas les 50 % de perte et
c'est là qu'on active plutôt un fond
d'urgence plutôt basé parce que là c'est
un sujet de trèsau plutôt basé
desminimis celui-là parce que ça on peut
pas déroger à ça deuxième élément je
reprends je reprends mon producteur de
fraise il a vu lui par la tempête ça
sert des truites en
verre pour éviter alors même système
normalement ils sont plutôt assurés en
particulier les seres en ver ils sont
plutôt assurés mais dès lors que comme
il y a quand même des franchises et que
vous pouvez avoir une ser a 10 ou 15 ans
vous avez un taux d'usure j'étais à la
tout à l'heure dans le Pas de calis le
gars qui a un robot de traite 15 ans
plus tard il vaut plus grand-chose Le
robot de traite et donc là il va vite
être plafonné par notre
système y compris de l'assurance
classique donc là c'est plutôt on
basculera en liaison je suis en train de
travailler avec les régions sur un fond
d'aide à l'investissement parce que là
ça nous affranchit de des des minimis
puisque là on peut aller à 65 % de taux
de subvention
faitadire état région vous voyez ce que
je veux dire donc sur la partie perte de
récolte plutôt fond d'urgence plutôt des
minimis et sur la partie investissement
qui va toucher beaucoup d'agriculteurs
dans cette affaire là euh le matos et
cetera le matériel pardon les enfin vous
avez compris ce que je voulais dire les
seres et le reste là pour le coup on est
plutôt sur un dispositif fond
d'investissement le le président de la
République a indiqué C ce matin ou ce
midi que on mettrait pour les deux
tempête plus inondation à date
aujourd'hui de ce qu'on sait 80 millions
d'euros cumulé sur fonds d'urgence et
fond d'investissement sachant qu'on peut
rajouter du fader jusqu'à 65 % et les
régions que j'ai eu ou vu j'ai vu le
président Bertrand aujourd'hui j'ai eu
un échange avec le président chîn Girard
ils m'ont dit qu'ils étaient ils étaient
après il faut qu'on se coordonne l'idée
étant on a un petit sujet c'est un sujet
d'essayer de débloquer ça assez vite bon
alors euh les calamités qu'on va qu'on
va qu'on va déclencher pour pouvoir
déclencher quand je vois ce que j'ai vu
pardon tout à l'heure en pas decalais
avec 1,20 d'eau il va falloir déjà qu'on
ait plus d'eau pour savoir ce qu'on a
sous les pieds hein ex
au mieux si on pouvait déclencher si si
on pouvait faire on en parlait tout à
l'heure avec mon conseil on pouvait
déclencher en si on pouvait documenter
tout de suite ça ferait passer fin
novembre ça ferait payer fin décembre
mais dès qu'on va déborder on va
déborder
oui on ira un peu plus vite pour cela
mais je vous donne la chronologie
c'est-à-dire tout ce que je peux
documenter aujourd'hui je peux aller au
calam je peux je peux le faire déclarer
c'est plutôt paiement fin décembre début
janvier c'est plutôt une course contre
le temps qu'on a là-dessus hein je le
dis franchement je prends ma fraise de
plugastel je reviens eux ils ont un
problème c'est s'ils veulent des fraises
à
plugastel parce que c'est c'est c'est là
qui on fait dans Bretagne mais pas il y
a pas qu'en Bretagne qu'on fait des
fraises ne me faites pas dire ce que
j'ai pas dit je vais me faire des
ennemis là il faut qu'il remett en
culture au 15
décembre donc faut qu'on regarde aussi
je vous mets la complexité mais je vous
dis qu'on essaie de trouver là je pense
qu'on a une panoplie d'outils qu'il faut
qu'on active il faut qu'on leur donne
l'autorisation de réinvestir pour
refaire sa serre avant qu'il touche les
indemnisations qu'on puisse ployer le
fond d'investissement bon on est en
train de regarder ça aussi voyez c'est
tout ça tout c toute cette tout cet
arbitrage et puis ceux qui ont pas perdu
de récolte là puis qui vont pas pouvoir
mettre en culture pendant 6 mois ça ça
c'est un un petit trou dans la raquette
je suis en train de regarder parce que
plus les perires de fond donc voilà
pardon je voulais c'est important d'en
parler parce que et d'essayer de
répondre des choses assez précises parce
que c'est un élément un gros élément
d'inquiétude c'est honnêtement la
tempête compliqué en Bretagne parce que
c'est des des pertes imens avec des tas
de troupes et alors les seres de moins
de 80
cm sont pas couvertes enfin bon bref
donc c'est là qu'on va faire
d'investissement plus facilement que
celles qui sont couvertes par un système
assurantiel parce que les petites seres
sont sont sont pas prises en charge
globalement en assurance par les
assureurs au-dessus c'est pris en charge
plus classiquement bon bref sur Haut-
de-fance aujourd'hui on voit mieux ce
que c'est parce que c'est un mécanisme
assez assez connu malheureusement
d'inondation ça va être de la catenat ça
va être de la la calamité seul problème
c'est à quel moment on va débloquer
pouvoir remettre en culture j'ajoute un
dernier élément je dis au passage je ve
dis en regardant le sénateur cers qui se
connaî ça par cœur c'est on va
simplifier on va on va on va évidemment
activer tous les mécanismes qui sont
liés à à la dérogation sur les
obligations de culture intermédiaire et
cetera parce que là on est un cas de
force majeur les obligations pack
doivent se retirer face aux éléments
climatiques parce que sinon on est chez
les fous hein je le dis donc ça on va
c'est à la main des préfets c'est c'est
mais on va le faire très vite pour
rassurer les agriculteurs qui disent moi
j'ai pas fait mon
implantation et comment je fais j'ai pas
fait ma rotation et comment je fais bah
oui c'est un cas de force ça s'appelle
un cas de force majeur et on va le faire
de façon mécanique dans C dans les
toutes les communes classées en en CAT
NAT manifestement va y avoir un problème
à rentrer dans les champsin et pour
avoir survolé tout à l'heure on va avoir
un gros problème à rentrer dans les
champs me semble-t-il
voilà merci Monsieur le Ministre alors
on va prendre des questions 3 par 3
Jean-Marc Boyer Christian Redon sarazi
et Dani Laurent
[Musique]
oui merci madame la Présidente un sujet
inquiète très sérieusement les maires
des communes rurales le zéro
artificialisation net le
zan ma question je la pose au ministre
d'agriculture et non au ministre de la
transition écologique après un recours
au Conseil d'État par la MF un travail
très important au Sénat qui a introduit
en particulier une garantie rurale d'un
hectare par commune la loi Zane est
l'exemple même de la décision verticale
imposé par la volonté d'une convention
citoyenne au détriment de la
concertation en amont avec les
principaux concernés les agriculteurs
les ruraux les conseils régionaux et
d'autres la FNSEA principal syndicat
agricole est opposé à l'application du
zan sans territorialisation et sans
différenciation à titre personnel je
pense qu'il est essentiel de laisser
plus de liberté aux zones rurales et de
faire confiance au bon sens paysans des
mes ruraux et des agriculteurs monsieur
le ministre quel est votre vre position
sur les dispositions du zan qui je le
répète suscit les plus grandes
inquiétudes dans nos campagnes question
subsidiaire que pensez-vous des
préconisations de la Cour des comptes
qui demande une diminution de 15 % du
Chapel bin français sous prétexte que
les vaches libère du méthan et du CO2 et
mett en danger la
planèteci Christian Redon sarazi oui
merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre deux sujets le premier concerne
l'indamnisation
pour abattage des troupeaux en
particulier dans les cas de tuberculose
bovine et et le niveau de fiscalité est
relativement élevé qui s'applique à ces
indemnisations qui effectivement couvre
une partie du du différentiel entre
valeur du stock et valeur de vendre mais
il y a dans le cas d'un abattage un un
grand nombre de dépenses annexes qui
viennent grver je dirais l'activité qui
font que une fiscalité
quasi stable telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui sur
sur sur ces sommes et est perçu par les
agriculteurs comme une injustice hein
donc voir si s'il n'y a pas peut-être
possibilité de de modulation là-dessus
et le deuxième sujet concerne les qui
est le la mesure phare vous l'avez dit
de de de du moment euh il y a aussi chez
chez les agriculteurs et en particulier
dans les département d'élevage et des
zones de boage une certaine injustice
qui est ressentie parce que certains les
ont conservés donc ils n'ont pas été
aidés pour les arracher ils ne sont pas
aidés pour les replter c'est un peu
double peine donc il voit passer des
trains et alors qu'en réalité les
vertueux ce sont peut-être eux Daniel
Laurent oui monsieur le ministre en
juillet dernier j'attiré l'attention du
Président de la République sur les
fortes inquiétudes de la filière viticol
quant à une éventuelle augmentation de
la fiscalité appliquée sur les boissons
alcoolisées j'ai une excellente nouvelle
et je vous en remercie il n'est pas
prévu d'augmentation de taxes et c'est
une bonne chose par contre la taxe Trump
ou où en est-on puisqueen novembre 2021
il y avait un accord qui avait été passé
avec l'administration Biden et sauf
erreur de ma part il n'y a pas il n'y a
toujours pas de de solution pérenne donc
c'est inquiétant l'année prochaine il y
a des élections américaines et quel en
est le
devenir chaque année la filière viticool
nous fait part de ces propositions dans
le cadre de la discussion budgétaire
portant sur la fiscalité des
transmissions
d'exploitation le soutien aux
exploitations viticoles face à
l'inflation ou l'élargissement du
périmètre des échanges de biens ruraux
entendez-vous répondre favorablement à
ces
attentes sur le projet européen de
règlement sur ça veut dire utilisation
durable des pesticides les vticulteurs
considèrent que les objectifs proposés
par la Commission européenne sont
déconnectés des réalités du terrain et
auront des conséquences pour l'ensemble
de la viticulture européenne il demande
que les ambitions réglementaires soient
équilibrées et accompagnées de mesures
concrètes de de compensation et une
dernière question le décret encadrant
l'agrivoltaïsme va être mis en
consultation publique les jeunes
agriculteurs notamment sont hostiles au
maintien d'un taux de 40 % de couverture
maximum d'une parcelle agricole il
demande 20
% une application immédiate du décret
pour éviter toute dérivve vous avez
parlé de la M MHE tout à l'heure vous
l'avez évoqué je sais que vous avez fait
un déplossement en nouvelle aququitainne
euh peut-être que il y a des
préconisations ou pas tout à l'heure
vous aviez l'air d'être ambigu dans
votre réponse est-ce que vous pourriez
préciser et juste vous en dernier lieu
les Chambres d'agriculture vous nous
font part de leur mécontentement sur les
moyens à loués qui ne sont pas la
hauteur des engés de leur mission merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre si vous voulez bien répondre à
ces TR à ces questions pas trois parce
qu'il y en a plus mais ces trois
cè sur le sur le
zan
il y a un travail qui a été fait on
prépare les décrets d'application enfin
bref je reviens pas sur un débat étant
moi-même un élu rural
doncant ayant été maire d'une commune de
700 habitants je vois à peu près le
sujet qui est qui est devant nous oui on
a besoin de différenciation territoriale
et on a besoin alors si j'étais très
honnête en 20 ans comment vousoulette
non mais en 20 ans dans ma commune un
hectare on les a on les avait pas
consommé bon alors le problème c'est que
au moment où qu'on la crise covid fait
qu'on aurait peut-être maintenant des
besoins qu'on a pas consommé pendant 15
ou 20 ans bon oui on a besoin de
différenciation moi je pense que le
sujet c'est d'ailleurs moi je ça
pourrait être un outil formidable
d'aménagement du territoire le zan et de
rééquilibrage du territoire si vous
voulez mon point de vue en disant bah
après tout les endroits il y a beaucoup
de concentration urbaine pour peut-être
mutualiser le gain si je peux dire et
pas continuer à faire ce qu'on fait
depuis 70 ans en France à faire tout
venir dans les villes bon moi je pense
que ça peut être un ça va être un objet
de débat avec les régions d'ailleurs que
je reste conseiller municipal et
conseiller communautaire je me réjouis
d'avance du débat que j'auris avec mon
président de région sur le sujet parce
que ça peut pas être totalement déuer de
ce qui est une stratégie territoriale y
compris pour les territoires ruraux
premier élément de réflexion deuxième
élément de réflexion sur
l'agriculture il y a un certain nombre
et c'est dans les décrets d'application
et ça j'y veille un peu pied à pied
parce que je vois bien que au gré de ce
que peuvent être les décrets
d'application ce qui a été la
philosophie générale que vous avez
notamment porté au Sénat de porter avec
bonne intelligence cette affaire là y
compris sur le sujet agricole faut pas
que ça devienne complètement maltusien
d'un point de vue agricole parce qu'à la
fin on va plus avoir aucun bâtiment
d'élevage et plus rien c'est oui c'est
c'est le risque alors j'ajoute au
passage ça c'est les normes
franco-français que il y a quasiment
plus aucun bâtiment d'élevage qui se
monte en Bretagne parce qu'il y a des
recours tous les matins sur tous les
bâtiments d'élevage et qu'il va falloir
qu'on simplifie tout ça je le dis parce
que les mêmes qui vous disent faut de
l'élevage c'est formidable les prairies
et cetera il trouve que c'est formidable
toutes les associations qui font desours
tout le temps contre tous les projets
j'étais l'autre jour au Space à Rennes
je sais plus si c'était dans le
Finistère ou dans le morbillant
peut-être dans le morbillant Bref plus
aucun projet de bâtiment d'élevage
depuis 24
mois donc ça c'est on va finir par
parler en théorie en fait donc on a
besoin je je fais une digression mais je
le dis parce que si en plus il y a le
zan qui s'applique dans des conditions
qui sont pas différencié on va avoir un
problème je je je partage je partage
votre point de vue donc en tout cas nous
on travaille sur la différenciation
et donc il faut qu'on réserve une partie
de la la l'artificialisation à des
projets de nature agricole on a aussi la
transformation dans l'affaire il me
semble que c'est un élément qui est un
élément très important deuxème élément
sur sur sur ce que je pense de les
préconisation de la Cour des comptes
alors je l'ai dit publiquement je le
redis je trouve que le rapport est de
qualité et que les les préconisations
sont sans objet et non'ont pas de sens
voilà je le redis là je je comprends pas
cette stratégie qui consiste c'est-àdire
on a un problème ce qu'on propose c'est
abattage massif disparition des éleveurs
quand par ailleurs on nous explique
qu'il faut d je vais revenir sur les des
prairies et queil participe au stockage
carbone et que par ailleurs si on est là
aussi très précis
intellectuellement on est plutôt pas
autosuffisant en
viande voilà donc il que cette stratégie
qui cons dire j'ai un problème ce que je
la trajectoire que je propose en fait
c'est de la
décroissance ça ça s'appelle de la décro
c'est un c'est un sujet que je je j'en
ai je m'en suis entretenu avec le
président de la Cour des comptes pour
président de la Cour des comptes je ne
comprends pas ce que vous avez
fait je je comprends pas parce que le
rapport n'est pas inintéressant sur Non
non mais franchement sur ce que peuvêtre
les réorganisations de la filière la
nécessité d'une d'une réorganisation
toujours reportée jamais faite
valorisation de
matière oui et et ça c'est intéressant
mais si ça se termine pas en fait on a
une solution pour résoudre le problème
c'est de faire disparaître c'est comme
si on disait je sais pas quoi pour que
les gens mangent moins il y a qu'à avoir
moins de gens voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est c'est un peu malthusien comme
construction et je trouve que cette
stratégie là est une stratégie toxique
et donc vous me trouverez jamais sur ce
chemin d'envoyer un message comme ça aux
agriculteurs non pas parce que je veux
leur faire plaisir mais c'est parce que
je pense ça et que tant qu'on n pas
autosuffisant on me raconte ce qu'on
veut j'ai dit ça l'autre jour à des
représentants de l'association écologie
son 50 % de la volille française on
n'est pas autosuffisant bah il va
falloir il va falloir il va falloir des
bâtiments en fait oui c'est j'en suis
confus mais il va falloir des
bâtiments parce que sinon on parle dans
le vide oui la taquine madame la
Présidente je reviendrai si vous voulez
donc voilà sur la question des des
indemnisations tub tuberculose pardon
euh d'abord on va revaloriser au mois de
février là parce qu'il y avait longtemps
que c'était demandé deuxème élément et
déduit alors peut-être que c'est la
manière mais je je reprends parler avec
vous mais on regardera avec mes équipes
et déduit sur la sur
la
la question du revenu fiscal est déduit
la part des charges induites par le
process normalement c'est ça ce qui est
prévu hein donc faut que vous me disiez
ce que pevent être les difficulté parce
que pour le coup c'est ça qui est prévu
deuxième élément j'ai lancé un travail
des travaux au sein du ministère avec la
Direction Générale de l'Alimentation
faut qu'on repense notre système
d'indemnisation sanitaire parce que
d'abord on en voit apparaître de plus en
plus le dérèglement climatique va nous
faire des
mauvais va nous jouer des mauvais tour
et donc on a besoin de penser ce que
notre système d'indemnisation parce que
sinon on va avoir des éleveurs qui vont
être de plus en plus rétifs mesures
sanitaires or les mesures je vois je
vois très bien pourquoi et et la
tuberculose faut qu'on arrive à essayer
de faire des mesures de prophylaxie qui
qui évite qu'elle se répande comme ça
après quand j'ai un problème de
bruxellos dans un département on vient
mepposer que il faut pas faire c faut
pas faire ça bon ok il faut rien faire
de même que j'ai un cas d'un cheval
qu'on a du mal qui a une maladie très
grave et qui la propriété d'un
propriétaire privé on en est à la 5è
procédure on peut toujours pas la battre
c'est c'est parfait hein ce genre de
c'est pas ce que vous avez dit mais
c'est pour dire qu'on a besoin de faire
prendre conscience que le sujet
sanitaire c'est pas un petit sujet c'est
grave pour les éleveurs et c'est grave
parfois d'un point de vue sanitaire
global V absolument donc cette question
de prophylactique est une élément
évidemment très important il me semble
que c'est c'est un élément très
important après les questions tax Trump
c'est on est à la fin du moratoire pour
l'instant c'est ça qui est en train de
se passer il vaudrait mieux qu'on le
fasse avant que puisse réapparaître la
perspective d'une tx Trump parceque une
taxe Biden peut-être pas mais une taxe
mais je me mê pas des élections
américaines je veux pas qu'on se met des
nôtres mais oui c'est travail qu'on
poursuit honnêtement pour l'instant
c'est un travail ou on poursuit ce
travail qui est pas un travail simple de
de et normalement la fin du moratoire
c'est
2026 donc c'est pas immédiat mais il
faut se mettre dans la perspective
d'échéances électorales que nous ne
maîtrisons pas et que je vrais pas
revoir parce que le la première mise à
mal de la viticulture ça a été les taxes
Trump he faut reconnaître après il y a
eu des tas d'autres éléments qui sont
importants deième élément sur les
Chambres
d'agriculture alors pour le coup
j'essaie d'être très vigilant et
d'ailleurs dans les dispositions qui
vont être proposé y compris dans la
suite du texte on a commencé à à
procéder une revalorisation j'ajoute que
une partie des fonds casses d'art en
plus c'est pour les Chambres
d'agriculture j'ajoute que sur les
sujets phitau ça rejoint ce qu'a dit le
sénateur DUP plomb on va mettre des
moyens pour les Chambres
d'agriculture vous me trouverez vigilant
parce que je pense que dans l'objet de
vulgarisation les chambes sont des
acteurs il y a les instituts techniques
euh filière animal et filière végétal et
il y a aussi les chambes d'agriculture
qui sont des tiers de confiance
vis-àvisagriculteurs qui sont quand même
très rétifs à ce que dit le ministre de
l'Agriculture ou l'écosystème que nous
représentons les Chambres d'agriculture
c'est un formudable outil pour massifier
et donc il me semble que c'est un
élément donc je je crois qu'on va
arriver à quelque chose qui pour les
chambres deagriculture leur permettra de
se doter des moyens qui sont me
semble-t-il des des moyens importants
sur le l'affaire du de
laagrioltaïisme on prend le temps parce
qu'on est pas d'accord voilà entre
d'abord la profession n'est pas tout à
fait d'accord on va pas se raconter
l'histoire va bien falloir qu'on tranche
bon 2ème élément j'ai du mal à 20 % ou
40 parce que si vous êtes en viti en
arbau en grande culture ou en prairie
avec des moutons 20 ou 40 ça va ENF moi
je veux bien tout mais ça veut pas dire
du tout la même chose en fait donc les
principes ont été posés me semble-t-il
moi je pense que le sujet principal si
vous me permettez c'est pas tant le taux
de couverture c'est où va l'argent
généré par les panneaux photovoltaïques
c'est c'est là qui est la question c'est
la répartition de la valeur ça permettra
d'éviter les les projets en opportunité
sans les agriculteurs ou à côté des
agriculteurs voyez ce que je veux dire
donc c'est plutôt là-dessus qu'on
travaille c'est plutôt là-dessus qu'il
faut qu'on travaille dans la répartition
parce que sinon on va avoir du mal à
être à la pression alors ceci étant et
je le dis parce que c'est une question
de responsabilité on peut pas dire il
faut des énergies de renouvelables et
pas et pas se poser la question qu'il
faut des méthaniseurs qu'il faut de
larivivoltaï sinon on peut avoir des on
peut avoir plutôt ça qui se développe
mais je suis pas sû que sur le
territoire ça soit tout à fait
l'enthousiasme qui guide les foules sur
ces sujets là parce que un moment il y a
eu un troplin aussi et donc l'énergie
renouvelable va bien falloir des
panneaux photos va bien falloir du
métaniseur faut peut-être qu'on
simplifie qu'on simplifie les choses et
sur la directive
sur je je l'ai dit publiquement donc
c'est tout à fait consignable je l'ai
dit devant la commission j'ai dit à la
commissaire en charge parce que c'est
pas le commissaire à laagri qui est en
charge c'est la Commissaire à la santé
je dis qu' d'abord il n'était pas
acceptable qu'on L dans un document que
une réduction de 20 à 30 % de la
production viticole n'était pas un
problème c'est un problème c'est un
problème euh c'est donc je l'ai dit
publiquement vous pouvez vous c'était
dans un il y a trois ou quatre conseils
j'ai dit c'est c'est vous pouvez pas
revenir devant des acteurs économiques
et leur dire qui peut dans cette salle
dire à un acteur économique vous allez
baisser de 30 % votre production et ne
vous inquiétez pas c'est pas un problème
deuxième élément je considère que c'est
un élément de l'influence européenne pas
que française hein la viticulture c'est
un nos nos porte notre por c'esture euré
oui je dis bien européenne donc on s'en
occupe avec quelques collègues plutôt
sur Rif sud de de la de l'Europe mais
enfin ça n'est pas acceptable et c'est
pour ça que d'ailleurs le texte sûr il
est pas encore adopté parce que je
considère que ce cette stratégie qui
consiste à dire en fait on assume y
compris dans le moment géopolitique
qu'on traverse on assume une
décroissance ici de la viticulture là
parfois des grandes cultures on peut
réduire de 10 à 15
% il me il me semble que il serait
prudent de d'être prudent il faut qu'on
arrête la naïveté sur la souveraineté
parce que la souveraineté c'est pas un
objet juste pour se faire plaisir et
parce que ça fait ça fait le tit du
ministre en partie c'est un objet de
sécurité parce que la souveraineté
énergétique la souveraineté militaire la
souveraineté alimentaire dans le monde
dans lequel on vit il y en a d'autres
hein souveraineté de santé si on ne sait
pas faire ça on prend un risque mortel
mais je donc il va falloir que les
consciences se prennent et moi je ne
peux pas entendre à la Commission des
gens qui m'expliquent que c'est pas
grave la décroissance parce que qui les
Brésiliens qui d'autes viend n nourrir
j'ai rien contre les Brésiliens mais les
Ukrainiens je vous ai entendu madame la
Présidente mais c'est pas le même sujet
le même espace on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'arler parce que je pense
que c'est c'est compliqué je reconnais
que c'est un sujet compliqué mais il que
c'est un élément sur lequel il faut
qu'on travaille mais on peut pas se
livrer dans les mains des autres se
nourrir cette année en bléure et en blé
on va
importer en provenance d'Ukraine
j'espère pas plus à l'est pas nous
Français mais d'ailleurs d'autres pays
bon moi ça me pose un problème je vous
le dis et voilà parce que c'est général
économique politique géopolitique et de
conscience voilà et donc c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que lundi prochain j'irai y
compris travailler sur la question de la
dérogation jaer parce que je n'ai je je
suis un garçon têtu je je n'ai pas fini
l'œuvre là-dessus donc sur sûr on a une
vigilance évidemment alors ceci étant
pardon je le dis au passage excusez-moi
madame la Présidente mais on essaie de
mettre en courelire un autre sujet qui
qui moi m'intéresse c'est nouvelle
technique génomique nouvelle NBT NGT
parce que c'est un élément de réponse à
vos impasses techniques et donc je dis
sû NBT NBT sûr et s'il y a sûr il y a
NBT et s'il y a pas sûr s'il y a pas NBT
il y a pas sûry il faut qu'on trouve un
point d'équilibre ça me paraît un
élément bah on fait une négociation
c'est c'est comme ça comme ça qu'il faut
travailler merci allez vous n'avez pas
répondu sur les E mais je pense que
Daniel vous savez c'est c'est c'est la
oui c'est les nouveaux convertis enfin
on peut pas reprocher aux gens d'être
convertis il y a il y en a qui n'ont pas
arraché leur ha ok mais enfin ils seront
pas pénalisés c'est juste
que il faut les aider plutôt à la
valorisation de la haie il faut pas
qu'il soit il faut que ils puissent moi
je pense ceux en particulier ils sont
très pénalisés dès qu'ils veulent
déplacer de 50 m on leur fait tout un
barnome avec des dossiers ép comme ça
donc il faut qu'ils aient de la
souplesse comme les autres parce que
ceuxl ils ont des qui sont existantes et
deux il faut qu'on leur trouve des vois
et moyens de valorisation trè élément
dans la pack on a des éléments une
partie de des éléments de reconnaissance
à l'écorégime ça passe par là est-ce
qu'il faudra faire évoluer pour
reconnaître ceux qui sont installés mais
réjouissons-nous si on en fait rentrer
d'autres c'est vrai que oui il y a ok
mais c'est mieux comme ça je comprends
le sentiment qui est noué en tout cas
faut pas qu'il soit plus pénalisé parce
qu'ils auraient le sentiment que ce
qu'on leur a demandé sans qu'on leur
demande ils l'ont fait et que maintenant
qu'on le demande aux autres il soit plus
pénalisé plutôt question de valorisation
y compris dans les points me semble-t-il
PAC merci Rémy Cardon Daniel Salmond et
Jean-Jacques
Michot merci madame la Présidente ma
question est la suivante puisque je
reprends vos propos monsieur le ministre
le bio a de l'avenir il faut qu'on lui
donne des moyens de son avenir enfin les
moyens de son avenir bon ça ce sont vos
mots comment comptez-vous articuler la
politique dirigé vers la l'agriculture
biologique pour lui donner les moyens de
son avenir sans oublier d'ailleurs les
petite structure bio alternative ma
question elle est j'ai j'ai aperçu qu'il
y avait effectivement un un budget
renforcé pour le bio à hauteur de de 10
millions d'euros on a le le PLF qui
arrive on a effectivement le des un
débat qu'on qu'on aura la chance d'avoir
prochainement aussi sur la vision de la
de l'agriculture française mais voilà en
l'état qu'est-ce que vous préconisez
quel est votre quels sont les moyens que
vous allez engendrer dans les dans les
prochains mois et dans les prochaines
années puisqueencore une fois il y a un
objectif de 18 % de surface en
agriculture biologique d'ici 2027 voilà
donc quel est le plan de bataille pour
atteindre au mieux 18 % ou voir plus
merci Daniel
salmon merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre j'étais tout à
l'heure devant l'Assemblée nationale à
une manifestation un rassemblement pour
les ma effectivement je vous confirme il
y a beaucoup de Bretons sans doute parce
qu'on parle de ès on part de très loin
Bretagne et que les mesures
agro-environnementales et climatiques
sont sont essentielles on a seulement 3
% des masses d'eau qui sont en bon état
en î Villen par exemple donc voilà il y
a un engagement de l'État on change pas
les règles au milieu de la partie donc
voilà ils ont besoin d'être rassurés et
d'être certain qu' qu'il vont toucher
c'estes Maï sur lesquel ils se sont
engagés depuis mai dernier euh c'était
pas mes questions mais c'était
simplement une petite remarque puis
qu'on est venu sur le sujet je voudrais
savoir quelle c'est la position de la
France sur le règlement sûr c'est
règlement de l'utilisation durable des
pesticides euh
ouais mais c'est un règlement qui est
quand même assez controversé puisque
c'est un règlement qui peut être quelque
part illusionniste en faisant croire
parfois qu'on diminue les pesticides
alors qu'on a simplement remplacé par
d'autres molécules donc voilà c'est un
règlement sur lequel il faudrait
peut-être se pencher puisque beaucoup de
choses se passent au niveau européen
donc si on part sur des des bases qui
sont un peu faussés ça pose problème la
question du renouvellement des des
générations euh euh bon on en parle
beaucoup parce que c'est un élément
central comment se fait-il que donc le
budget du programme haita il est stable
à 12 millions d'euros euh est-ce que ce
n'est pas le moment d'augmenter aussi ce
budget là dernière chose on a on a parlé
des des moyens des chambres
d'agriculture euh qui demande un
déplafonnement de la taxe additionnel
sur le foncier non bâti quelle est votre
position sur le sujet euh en plus des
autres financements dont vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure et si on augmente les
moyens des chambres d'agriculture est-ce
que
derrière on va avoir des
conditionnalités sur plus de pluralisme
au sein des chambres d'agriculture un
pluralisme qui serait qui serait
bienvenu voilà et puis sinon simplement
arrêtons sur les sur les raccourcis
également les les petites caricatures
aussi sur les poulets par exemple je
viens de regarder là sur Internet on
parle les importations de poulet mais
nos exportations ont augmenté de 2 %
entre 2020 et
2021 et on a 500 millions qui de de
retours des de nos exportations de
poulet donc quand on parle importation
faut parler exportation également merci
Jean-Jacques Michot oui madame la
présidence monsieur le ministre ma
question elle vient en complément de
celle de mon collègue Rémi Raymond
remémi Cardon sur la filière bio
effectivement vous avez prévu au budget
un un des aides pour cette filière mais
surtout pour la promotion de de la
filière et sur l'alimentation par contre
aujourd'hui c'est de la trésorerie qu'on
besoin les les entreprises elles sont à
la limite de la de de de et pourquoi
vous n'avez pas gardé un amendement
transpartisan à l'Assemblée nationale
qui était pour des aides
actuelles le ministre si vous voulez
bien répondre pardon je vais être un peu
direct sur cette question là parce que
c'est c'est c'est très commode pardon
je je serai probablement un jour dans
l'opposition je suis
lucide mais un jour j'espère que je ne
ferai pas il y a un problème monsieur le
ministre on va faire un petit amendement
parce que je rappelle que dans ces débat
au Sénat j'avais un amendement à 800
millions un amendement à 500 millions et
à la fin pour faire bonne mesure on a
dit on a qu'à prendre celui à 200 bon
pardon j'espère que franchement je c'est
pas sérieux quoi en fait je vous le dis
franchement après on me dit c'est 15000
€ par exploitation la règle des minimis
tout le bazar tout ça n'a pas
d'importance c'est pas grave on s'est
fait plaisir pendant une demi-heure à
l'Assemblée nationale je le dis cache
mais en fait tout ça c'est on vend du
rêve et on va décevoir beaucoup de gens
donc je n'aime pas faire ça je vous le
dis très franchement donc ce ce truc qui
consiste à quand on est dans
l'opposition en l'occurrence à
l'Assemblée nationale parfois même quand
on est dans la
majorité à dire c'est plus commode de
dire il y a enfin on m'a dit un milliard
mais d'où pourquoi comment enfin je veux
dire faut faut être sérieux et on sa on
sait très bien en plus que sur mécanisme
d' de trésorerie on est on est bloqué
par la règle des minimis alors on peut
dire c'est la faute à l'Europe après on
dira c'est à cause de l'Europe que vous
n'avez pas votre aide enfin tout ça
pardon ça n'est pas sérieux je le dis
très franchement donc après je vais
répondre en doublon puisque vous avez
été plusieurs à m'interpeller sur la
question du bio d'abord ce qu'on fait ce
qu'on ce qu'on ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
quand même d'abord le crédit d'impôt
c'est 100 million
d'euros les aides à la conversion c'est
3 140 million d'euros c'est 40 % de plus
que la précédente programmation hein B
c'est des faits ce que je dis c'est
c'est documentable c'est des faits c'est
c'est évident et les aides d'urgence les
aides d'urgence c'est 70 millions
d'euros plus ce qu'on a rajouté dans
l'écorégime puisque j'ai veillé moi-même
y compris parfois contre certains à
faire en sorte qu'il y a un différentiel
de 30 € par hectare pour ceux qui
étaient en bio on me dit il fallait 50
ok enfin c'est 50 millions d'Ur 50 + 70
+ 340 + 100 bon ça fait des sommes je
veux dire il y a pas rien sur le bio le
risque principal vous avez raison vous
l'avez dit en polyphonie c'est un risque
de déconversion c'est queil y ait pas de
conversion cette année l'année suivante
donc on va avoir des crédits il faudra
qu'on se pose la question et ça je ne le
saurai qu'au mois de décembre mais il
faudra qu'on se pose la question de en
quoi ils servent la cause du bio si je
peux dire deuxième élément comment on
fait en sorte que ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui convertis ne se
déconvertissent pas et moi j'ai des
témoignages je le reconnais de gens qui
sont en Bur depuis 5 10 ou 15 ans et qui
disent cette année là c'est donc il faut
qu'on travaille là-dessus mais c'est pas
des aides d'urgen c'est pas 15000 €
le sujet c'est est-ce que j'ai une
perspective qui leur dit il y a de la
consommation au bout trème élément je le
dis son ultra libéral je crois que la
perte de BIOS c'est entre 1 et 1
milliard 5 d'euros sur 2022 c'est pareil
en 2023 la baisse de consommation
chiffre d'affaires c'est pas à l'état de
compenser ça pardon donc il faut qu'on
soutienne là pour répondre à votre
question la consommation pour le moyen
terme et donc c'est la
comme il faut qu'on embarque aussi je le
dis la grande distribution parce que
quand ça allait bien avec la croissance
était à deux chiffres personne s'est
posé de question compris parfois par la
filière quand ça va bien on se pose
jamais de question voilà à 10 points
d'augmentation par an on se disait ça va
bien ça va monter jusqu'au ciel les les
grandes surfaces on a monté des magasins
partout on a mis des grandes surfaces
qui ont mis des des surfaces en bio
partout et maintenant que ça va pas bien
il y a plus rien c'està dire que la
grande distribution ne joue pas le jeu
et donc on a besoin collectivement je le
dis là vous parce que c'est on a besoin
de dire à la grande
distrie vous voulez du bio vous voulez
plus de bio en fait parce qu'ils sont
aussi leur responsabilité on sait très
bien que là
quand c'est présent dans les étales les
gens consomment plus que quand ça
disparaît dans les étal et puis dernier
élément sur la grande distribution comme
ça ça fera un petit lot pour tout le
monde pourquoi la grande distribution
marge plus sur le bio que sur les
autres non non non il marge plus ah non
non il marge plus monsieur le
sénateur
comment oui ok c'est
l'argumentation en tout cas moi je je
pense qu'on a un dialogue donc on a un
la d'urgence on verra à la fin de
l'année parce que moi mon obsession
c'est de pas en perdre parce qu'on a un
objectif à tenir il faut déjà qu'on
perde pas de surface deuxème élément la
communication parce qu'il y a que comme
ça il faut qu'on casse deux choses c'est
le bio c'est du local aussi or quand
vous voyez la baisse de conso elle n
liée d'abord
elle arrive en 2021 après la covid parce
que les gens se sont sont allés beaucoup
vers le local et on ont indifférencier
local ou local et bio vous voyez donc il
faut qu'on réitère l'idée que le bio et
de faut qu'on tue l'image qui est
parfois un peu faussé de le bio c'est ça
n'est pas accessible budgétairement même
si c'est ça peut être plus élevé je dis
pas le contraire mais il faut qu'on
casse ça trème élément il faut que on
arrive nous état dans nos restaurations
scolaires après il y aura ce qu'on a à
faire hospitalier et autres mais qu'on
fasse en sorte qu'on atteigne les
objectifs des
Galim les 20 % faut qu'on les atteigne
bon et après faut qu'on arrive à
encourager on peut pas demander à l'État
de le faire partout on encourage les
collectivités sans leur donner la leçon
à dire vous regardez j'étais l' l'autre
jour à
Dijon la métropole plus le département
ils sont pas de mêmes obédiences
politiqu en plus ils atteignent les
objectifs des galimes
bon et il y a plein d'endroits où on
arrive à les atteindre donc il faut
qu'on encourage les collectivités
parfois c'est des freins de logistique
d'organisation et cetera voilà les
éléments il me semble-t-il qu'on peut
poser sur la question sur la question du
bio euh oui donc c'est pour ça que je
pense que vous voyez comment je le dis
je je serai pas de ceux qui assis sur le
bord du chemin disent voyez bien le buo
savait pas d'avenir j'ai jamais cru ça
et au moment de la crise je le crois
encore moins voyez enfin je le dirais
encore moins que ceux qui parfois ont
tendance à dire voyez c'était une erreur
après euh partout en Europe quand vous
parlez avec les collègues il y a quand
même les marchés se stabilisent et on
est dans un moment de crise et donc
c'est plus compliqué le bio aujourd'hui
qu'hier voilà mais il faut qu'on arrive
à tenir une trajectoire ne serait-ce que
ne serait-ce que pour une un sujet
budgétaire on a mis des moyens dans le
bio c'est pas pour avoir perdu tous ces
efforts parce que vous faites une
conversion vous mettez pendant 5 ans des
moyens de l'Union européenne ou de
l'État et puis pu au la 6e année les
gens se déconvertisent c'est quand même
un échec collectif donc c'est ça qu'il
faut d'abord éviter et c'est ça qu'on va
lequel on va essayer de travailler
monsieur sénateur salement je reviens
pas sur les mes on s'est déjà
dit là aussi je je je comme ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur l'amendement
pardon assemblée national mais au moins
ça a été dit et je le redirai tout aussi
publiquement faut que chacun a compris
les organisations syndicales soient vre
avec responsabilité c'est pas la boîte
ouverte partout parce que ce qu'on met
là on peut pas le mettre partout parce
que la sujets budgétaires sont des
sujets un peu complexes sur la i de la
France sur S alors c'est la verersion
inverse de votre collègue vous vous
dites que c'est tronqué il y en a pas
assez j'ai l'impression que votre
collègue trouve qu'il y en a un peu trop
bon la position c'est que un je veux des
débats sur les phyos qu'au niveau
européen et j'en plus jamais en France
on vient me me faire des débats de nous
on est plus malin que les autres voilà
ce qui explique ce que je dis sur bien
beaucoup de ces sujets là de c'est notre
intérêt parce que de toute façon on
fermera jamais la frontière aux
Allemands aux Italiens aux Espagnols les
clos miroir c'est extérieur Union
européenne donc quand on dit j'interdis
chez moi bah ça veut dire j'interdis pas
chez les autres et que je crée des
concurrents qui sont parfois plutôt des
amis enfin avec les Belges avec les
deuxième élément faut qu'on ait des
trajectoires qui soient créd parce que
quand vous regardez entre sur
restauration de la nature ed parfois sur
les mêmes exploitants ça va faire
beaucoup alors sauf à qu'il y a des gens
qui a des stratégies décroissantes mais
il va falloir qu'il sorte du bois il va
falloir qu'on voit si ça tient non pas
pour faire de l'hyper productivisme je
sais pas quoi faut voir si ça tient
économiquement et en terme de
souveraineté si ça m'affae pas tout
j'étais avec mon collègue irlandais faut
qu'on alors eux ils sont très
exportateurs de de viande donc eux ça
leur nous c'est pas le sujet hein alors
je reprends votre volaille non mais la
volaille on en exporte le sol de net
c'est 50 % c'est le net dont je vous
parle oui le net ah si si c'est le net
donc j'ai un problème net après que dans
les marchés oui le port on en on on en
sort on en rentre mais le sold de net
est neutre légèrement positif sur le
port OK
sur la viande bovine c'est encore comme
ça mais c'est en train de se dégrader
donc voilà donc je je je dis juste sur
sûr il faut qu'on regarde c'est oui une
trajectoire de réduction oui c'est
intéressant y compris dans les process
d'homologation on est des process
d'homologation ou d'interdiction qui soi
un peu homogénéisé et que chacun fasse
pas comme il veut dans son coin je pense
c'est mieux franchement je pense que
c'est plus quand chacun quand c'est
plutôt au niveau européen que se prendre
prennent des décisions quand il y a des
le biocontrôle je trouve que parfois on
est un peu lent à l'homolog produit de
contrôle et alors quand j'entends des
boîtes françaises des start-ups qui
disent je vais faire homologuer mon
produit ailleurs parce qu'en France
c'est 4 ans ou 5 ans et ça coûte trop
cher c'est un crève cœur je vous le dis
et donc je préférrais qu'on a un process
homologué enfin unique harmonisé au
niveau européen ça nous fera gagner en
plus du temps dernier point budget on va
pouvoir en reparler mais dans le débat
budgétaire qui se nourrira au
Sénat à date et ça couvre le besoin tel
qu'il est après demain faudra qu'on
faudra qu'on regarde y compris dans le
pacte et dans la loi ce que peuvent être
des moins supplémentaires s'il y a des
besoins supplémentaires on les prendra
on les on les identifiera s que ça c'est
une bonne facture que de pas anticiper
trop que parfois on a tendance à faire
du déclamatif on dit on crois que c'est
autoréalisateur voyz ce qu'on dit on dit
je double le budget d' et ça va doubler
les installations non il faut qu'on
double les installations et après le
budget d' se se s'alignera et puis
dernier élément sur le pluralisme
contenu de la formation politique dont
je suis originaire je suis très attaché
au pluralisme enfin le pluralisme c'est
aussi
faut faire des voix en fait mais oui
donc on peut pas me demander de
compenser la perte de voix voyez je je
le dis c'est bête mais il y a un moment
faut juste faire des voix bah le
pluralisme c'est ça et moi vous me
trouverez jamais une manière de compter
comment une manière de compter bah une
manière de compter une voix est une voix
5 % c'est 5 % et 3 % c'est 3
% on en reparlera mais il y a pas de
querelle au pluralisme de ce mais il y a
pas que les syndicats non plus il y a
d'autres organisations euh ah alors
après ça c'est sur l'organisation
d'installation j'ai dit depuis le début
que je voulais qu'il y ait un guichet
unique qui s'impose à tous parce que les
gens qui s'installent sans regarder la
question climatique sans regarder la
résilience de leur système et qui 5 ans
après sortent et on a on a brisé des
vies et des rêves et je je j'aime pas ça
alors il y a des modèles alternatifs de
nature diverse moi ça me gêne pas en soi
mais faut faut que ça tienne
économiquement donc tout le monde passe
à la
toise comment il faut tre très atttif
ouais tout le monde doit passer tout le
monde doit passer à la toise de pardon
on va regarder si votre système on n pas
à vous dire que climatiquement
qu'économiquement ça passe ou ça passe
pas deuxème élément le corollaire c'est
que toutes les formes d'install enfin
toutes les formes d'accompagnement
soient autorisé enfin je veux dire que
dans le la guiché unique chacun puisse
et donc dans la loi telle que c'est
prévu l'idée c'est de dire on fait
qualifier des des structures ou des gens
dans des structures qui pourront
apporter l'accompagnement donc entrée
unique puis après après il faudra
veiller à ce que ça soit bien opérant
dans toutes les chambres d'agriculture
troisème élément il va falloir que ceux
qui se sentaient en marge décident de
jouer dans le jeu et pas continuer à
cultiver le côté marginal je leur avais
dit moi il y a un certain nombre de
structures qui depuis des années
accompagn mais moi je suis pas ceci je
suis pas cela moi je fais et qui font
plutôt du bon accompagnement je
considère mais faut qu'ils acceptent de
rentrer entre guillemets dans un système
unique et ils auront leur identité parce
que ça sera ça sera pas tout et le
contraire de tout si on dit que tout le
monde doit passer à la toise et que
c'est un guichet unique c'est un guichet
unique et je Seris
moi du Guchet unique et du pluralisme
dans le guichet unique mais ceux qui
vont dire ah ouais mais il est pas
vraiment pluraliste je mets à
l'extérieur je fais mon con alors là là
on va avoir un problème voilà mais moi
je l'ai dit depuis le début je sais très
bien qu'à la fin certains vont dire ah
non c'est pas assez pluraliste pu en
fait je peux pas imposer mon modèle je
me j'ai personne n imposé son modèle
mais personne il faut que celui qui a
envie de passer par terre de lien passe
par terre de lien celui qui veut passer
par les cvam passe par les CIVAM celui
qui veut passer par la Chambre réseau
classique il passe par la chambre réseau
classique mais il faut que
chacun se respecte et
parfois ceux qui sont plus en marge ont
du mal aussi à comprendre que il faut
qu'ils respectent ce qui étaient plutôt
les majoritaires de d'organisation voilà
c'est compliqué hein de d'accepter qu'on
est
minoritaireite alors Anne-Catherine
Loisier Daniel grrimiller Henry
Cabanel merci mer madame la Présidente
Monsieur moi je vais aller si vite
d'abord effectivement pour saluer les
les efforts du gouvernement en faveur de
la de la filière for bois qui le mérite
bien et qui en a véritablement besoin et
notamment vous l'avez dit Monsieur le
Ministre concernant la la forêt privée
qui
singulièrement bénéficier de peu de
moyens au regard de de de l'importance
géographique et de la et du potentiel en
fait de matériaux bois donc voilà bravo
pour pour cet effort
conséquent vous dire quand même que
concernant la la for répui et notamment
les communes forestières euh je crois
qu'il sera important de stabiliser à
minimum les moyens de de de de l'ONF et
d'enlever cette espèce d'épée d'amoclesè
aujourd'hui qui demeure sur les forêts
publi avec ce ce schéma d'emploi qui
était programmé initialement jusqu'en
2026 à la baisse je rappelle quand même
qu'il y a aujourd'hui 900000 hectares de
forêts publiqu qui sont sans documents
de gestion que le travail qui est fait
par exemple par les communes forestières
sur les bien 100 m c'est aujourd'hui
plus de 100000 hectares qui sont entre
guillemets récupérés et qui sont donc
sans documents de gestion durable donc
il y a encore beaucoup d'efforts
d'accompagnement et de soutien aux élus
qui sont quand même confrontés sur les
territoires à tous ces ces ces ces
difficulté d'acceptabilité hein de de de
l'exploitation forestière et puis aussi
d'explosion du coût aujourd'hui la
moyenne de de de coût de renouvellement
forestier par hectare c'est ça dépasse
facilement les 8000 € euh et donc les
plafonds d'aide par exemple pour le
renouvellement sont tellels qu' en fait
ce ne sont pas des aides à 80 % comme ça
apparaît dans les documents mais de
facto comp tenu de l'explosion des coûts
parce que dans la forêt comme dans tous
les autres secteurs malheureusement
l'inflation euh frappe c'est euh
finalement autour des 50 % d'Aid pour
les communes donc chacun comprend que 50
% à raison de 8000 € par hectare ça fait
4000 € d'aide plus les risques s'il y a
pas de reprise euh d'avoir à rembourser
euh les aides enfin il y a je je je
salue les dispositifs mais je soulligne
les difficultés et le poids aujourd'hui
si 6 8000 € en moyenne d'aide de
reconstitution des parcelles avec là
aussi des des des des coûpts de
protection du gibier qui ont explosé
voilà mais il faut tout mettre dans la
balance et voilà euh donc vraiment une
attention à à la forêt publique et
d'ailleurs je je m'interrogeais parce
que nous ne retrouvons pas dans les
éléments budgétaires en fait les suites
de la ventilation du fond tempête qui
avait été voté par le Sénat à
l'initiative d'ailleurs du rapporteur
Husson en
2021 et donc ce serait intéressant qu'on
puisse retirer le fil de ce de ce fond
et savoir comment il a été utilisé est
ce qui est ce qu'il devient aujourd'hui
et comment on peut le le mobiliser pour
pour la suite des opérations souligner
rapidement le sujet de la TA TFNB mais
on en a déjà parlé pour s'assurer
effectivement que son sa désindexation
bénéficiera aussi aux acteurs forestier
puisque 30 % de la taxe additionnelle à
taxe foncière émane des propriétés
forestières et puis enfin sur le GNR
monsieur le ministre on l'a rapidement
évoqué mais je tiens quand même à
souligner le fait que les entreprises de
la filièrebois à ma connaissance à ce
jour ne bénéficie pas des dispositifs
qui sont ceux des entreprises agricoles
et donc ça augure pour elle de grandes
grandes difficultés pour assumer les
charges qui sont devant elle Daniel
gramiller
oui madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers
collègues je je vais prolonger la
question al tout de suite de
d'annecatherine sur dossier forestier
moi je salue on salue tous ce plan sans
précédent de soutien à la plantation
mais il y a deux sujets qu'il faut
réussir dans un vous avez la
responsabilité sur le territoire
effectivement quand on voit qu'on met
quand on met 1 € faut mettre
pratiquement 0,40 € pour la protection
du plan c'est vraiment l'exemple du
gaspillage tout ça parce qu'on a pas un
équilibre siveau génétique sur le
terrain et c'est vous qui avez la
responsabilité au niveau des comités
paritaires dans la région et c'est vous
qui avez la déclinaison aussi ensuite
département par
département deuxième point ça serait
dommage qu'on ait mis autant de moyens
et que derrière on nit pas la capacité à
faire que ce plan devienne une tige
adulte et aujourd'hui la dimension de
l'entretien c'est pas parce qu'on a
planté que pour autant le plan va
devenir adulte donc il y a le problème
d'entretien derrière qui n'est pas
encore aujourd'hui pris dans sa
dimension qu'il est absolument
nécessaire de traiter l'autre aspect que
je voulais évoquer vous l'avez traité
donc je vais être très très court c'est
sur les NTG une nouvell technique
génomique là il y a un vrai sujet et la
France devra être au rendez-vous vous y
avez partiellement répondu et sur le bio
je crois qu'il faut dire les choses
aussi moi je va prendre un exemple vécu
ce qui est pas si lointain c'est
l'exemple
du des produits allégers celui qui ne
vendait pas de produits allégers ne
disparaissait des rayons B les produits
allégers ils ont disparu parce que le
consommateur n'en voulait plus vous
pouviez toujours continuer de faire
autant de pub que vous vouliez c'est
parce que le consommateur n'en voulait
plus moi je voulais attirer votre
attention monsieur le ministre sur un
point très clair mais vous le savez
peut-être aujourd'hui vous avez des
producteurs bio qui livrent dans dans
des produits conventionnels qui en terme
de revenu gagnent autant que si dans le
bio parce que le lait au niveau du
conventionnel dès lors qu'il y a une
valorisation et rénumérateur donc
arrêtons de d'opposer c'est pas parce
qu'il est pas affiché bio que pour
autant le système n'existe pas et il
peut perdurer il faut pas opposer les
systèmes et dernier point c'est sur les
bâtiments d'élevage je trouve là
regrettable qu'on ne débouche pas sur le
traitement des toit amienté pour en
faire de l'énergie donc traiter le
problème sanitaire faire de l'énergie et
faire du stockage d'eau je crois que
s'il y a bien un point d'urgence à
réaliser et là il y a aucune perspective
vous savez que le CADA a été très
mobilisé là-dessus il y a eu des
amendements on a demandé au gouvernement
de bouger compris sur le texte sur les
énergies renouvelables et je on ne voit
rien apparaître alors que aujourd'hui il
y a urgence à le traiter Henri Cabanel
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre d'abord merci pour
l'augmentation donc du budget je je je
vais pas revenir sur le bio mais je
partage aussi la crainte de de de mes
collègues malgré les efforts que vous
pouvez que vous pouvez faire eu mais
est-ce que réellement les objectifs que
vous êtes fixés c'est-à-dire 18 % en
2027 et 21 % en 2030 en 2030 avec la
conjoncture estce des obj que vous allez
atteindre quand même moi je voudrais
revenir sur l'assurance récolte euh donc
depuis la création de l'assurance
récolte il n'y a eu que un faible
pourcentage d'exploitations qui se sont
inscrites dans ce schémal euh et vous
savez très bien que sur certaines
filières
donc il y a le problème de la moyenne
olympique
avez-vous avancé sur ce sujet comme vous
vous l'aviez dit l'année dernière me
semble-t-il euh concernant donc la la la
taxe à tritronéux des terrains
agricooles aant changé
d'affectation cette taxe qui est
réservée à l'installation des jeunes
pourriez-vous nous nous nous nous
détailler les actions qui sont engagées
avec cette taxe-l et et et dernière
petite
question seriez-vous favorable à une
taxe du foncier non bâti différente
suivant que la terre soit cultivée ou
pas pour éviter donc les friches
agricoles voilà Monsieur le
Ministre
euh merci beaucoup commune forestière
enfin les sujets forestiers
euh alors non je je tiqu que 8000 €
l'hectar alors peut-être avec protection
cynergétique si je peux dire
euh alors après on est sur la base de ce
que sont les barêes on peut regarder
c'est question des BR quand on déploa
mais je vais vous dire le le le le point
d'inquiétude principal que j'ai sur le
déploiement en commune privée de nature
privée c'est qu'on est alors c'est pour
ça que j'ai réclamé d'ailleurs que les
moyens budgétaires les 250 millions
soient sous pavillon ministère de
l'agriculture c'est qu'on ait des
procédures qui soient trop complexes
c'estàd que j'entend beaucoup de
propriétaires festiers qui me disent
c'est trop complexe ce dossier est
compliqué euh donc on a besoin d'avoir
des procédures où on vient pas
incrémenter toutes les conditionnalités
de la terre qui fait qu'à la fin come on
disait l'autre ils ont les mains propres
mais ils ont plus de mains quoi
c'està-dire que à la fin c'est c'est
parfait notre truc est génial il y a
tout qui va bien mais en fait personne
ne plante et en fait on perd tout le
stockage carbone la biodive la
production de bois donc je serais assez
ass serai vigilant sur ce sur ce point
là de simplification on peut regarder
ensemble mais on en parlera sur la
question des cûpts ça me permet de
répondre à la question de Monsieur enfin
de faire écho à la la à la question de
Monsieur grimier que vous évoquez sur la
question chasse enfin après enfin oui
alors on l'a dans la main il faut qu'on
c'est c'est c'est reconnaissons que
c'est un sujet un peu compliqué vous le
savez les uns et les autres comme moi
parce que pour être praticien parfois de
cette activité je je vois toutes les
réticences d'un certain nombre de gens à
à faire et à atteindre les objectifs des
des prélèvements qui sont fixés avec
dans une logique de ben il faut pas
tirer les les les femelles parce que ça
va çaera ça fera plus de de petit
l'année dernière enfin ceux qui ont pas
vu ça non pas compris la logique qui est
à l'œuvre qui est une logique un peu de
la croissance c'est formidable ça fera
des tableaux le recul de la de la chasse
au petit JB on va dire les choses comme
il sont donc oui il y a des décisions
vous avez raison monsieur sénateur REM
au niveau départemental mais il y a
besoin que collectivement on disent aux
chasseurs que c'est leur intérêt
d'arrêter ça parce que mettre 40 % des
coûts et c'est moi qui le dis c'est le
périmètre MTE mais j'en ai parlé avec
Christophe B j'ai dit on va pas mettre
40 % 250 millions pour protéger parce
qu'on est pas capable de prélever ce
qu'il faut notamment en servidé c'est
impossible c'est intenable comme
comme position j'en ai parlé je l'ai dit
d'ailleurs publiquement l'autre jour à
l'ONF je pense qu'il a un moment y
compris alors pour le coup pour moi ça
pourrait être un critère les gens qui ne
font pas leur leur tableau qui ne je
vois pas pourquoi on leur mettrait des
aides pour financer des clôtures ou des
manchons ENF en tout cas à ce point-là
je pense qu'il y il y a quand même un
moment alors c'est pas une science
exacte on y arrive pas toujours bref
mais enfin quand même si vous en avez 10
à faire et vous en faites que deux vous
avez un petit sujet voilà ça veut dire
que vous avez une stratégie
d'augmentation
population que que qui va nous amener
dans le mur et qui va amener la chasse
dans le mur je le dis très
tranquillement ça va amener la chasse
dans le mur ce truc parce que moi je
fais pas un déplacement alors un coup
c'est les sangliers donc c'est moins les
forêts encore que encore que on pourra
regarder euh et donc on a besoin de
réfléchir à une stratégie qui qui garde
des des animaux mais on a des densités
qui sont
intenables voilà et on va pas payer des
clôtures on n pas quand même je trouve
que on va pas multiplier les clôtures
sauf dans les endroits parce que déjà
renouvellement forestier c'est compliqué
la reprise c'est compliqué si en plus on
a du de la pression de JB trop forte on
va jamais y arriver donc je suis
d'accord avec vous là-dessus ta TFNB on
va regarder parce que vous m' avez saisi
il y a quelques jours sur le GNR
forestier alors on les mesures de défis
qu'on a dont on a parlé avec le sénateur
DUP plomb ça c'est pour l'agricole nous
on est en train de regarder alimenter un
fond pour moderniser les équipements des
forestiers dans la logique de
décarbonation voez dans leur logique
d'investissement qu'on les accompagne au
travers d'un fond qui pourrait
représenter environ 20 millions d'euros
ce qui est la part qui est prélevé chez
eux donc on est en train de travailler
là-dessus et on en pararlera au moment
du débat budgétaire pour donner droit à
cette demande qui qui est pas illégitime
au moment où on a en plus besoin d'eux
on aura des tas d'autres sujets
là-dessus me semble-t-il que c'est un
fond tempête on va pour le coup là je
peux pas vous répondre là là vous vous
là vous levez me poser une colle mais on
va on va regarder le sujet parce que
c'est 21 donc ça me fait loin mais on va
regarder avec mes équipes et on vous
apportera évidemment la réponse sénateur
grrimier je sais que c'est un sujet qui
vous tient à cœur sur la question des
bâtiment d'élevage pour l'instant on n
pas la martingal honnêtement moi j'avais
idée compris dans la
répartition de la valeur de ce que sont
le de laagri voltaïisme de se poser la
question de savoir si ça pouvait pas
alimenter un fond qui aurait permis
d'aller sur les bâtiments d'élevage et
je pense que dans dans le les décrets
d'application dans le le sujet de à quoi
peuvent servir un fond mutualisé il me
semble que ça ça pourrait servir parce
que ça permettrait évidemment de régler
des problèmes de bâtiment d'élevage et
une modernisation et donc les sujets
d'élevage et deux de faire du
photovoltaïque parce que parfois moi je
j'ai compris des cas que je connais bien
de gens qui vous expliquent on peut pas
ils peuvent pas faire sur bâtiment et
donc ils vont faire sur
terrain qui est quand même un petit peu
iconoclasse si je peux dire dans une
logique qui est plutôt une logique
d'essayer d'économiser les terres on a
un sujet d'ailleurs assurance aussi
alors que sur lequel je je me suis j'ai
saisi c'est les assureurs qui ne veulent
pas assurer certains bâtiments dès lors
qu'il y a du photovoltaïque sous réserve
de ce qui sou le bâtiment donc ça faut
qu'on regarde aussi avec les assureurs
parce que c'est valable pour le bois
d'ailleurs c'est valable là pour
d'autres domaines me semble-t-il
euh le bio vous avez dit donc je je
raison qu' faut pas à la fois opposé en
même temps il y a des la question du
lait c'est de valoriser globalement et
après ça peut se faire un peu en
différence sur le bio mais la question
du lait c'est une question de
valorisation si on veut installer des
gens je finis avec le sénateur Cabanel
sur le bio toujours ça me fait le joint
bah moi je je fais en sorte qu'on tienne
les objectifs par que c'est des
engagements qu'on a pris alors on va on
va prendre du retard je va pas vous
raconter de SNET bon moi j'essaie de me
mettre en situation de retrouver une
trajectoire pour ce qu' dit pour faire
quoi ce qu' dit le sénateur Cardon aussi
c'est j'essaie de de trouver une
trajectoire crédible euh on va pas être
facile sur 23 et 24 on va pas se
raconter l'histoire
après essayons de trouver une
trajectoire qui nous amène aux objectifs
que N nous sommes assignés sinon il y a
un sujet assurance récolte je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord avec vous il y a
encore des trops dans la raquette on
sait qu'on a quelques sujets marécha été
dit sans doute arbau euh qui avait été
un peu identifié d'ailleurs au démarage
enfin on a quand même quelque chose qui
marche puisque en prérie on est passé de
0,5 % des surfaces à 9
% je parle pas de la viitier des grandes
cultures qui sont déjà assz haut et sur
la partie sur la partie donc toute
culture confondue on a une augmentation
de 36 % des surfaces
entre de 22 et 23 donc ça marche quand
même c'est 1liion 7 hectar 2
milliion
ou oui c'est de non c'est 2 millions
c'est ça c'est 2 millions d'hectares de
plus quasiment bon ça va se voir parce
qu'on est 6 5 millions d'hectares qui
sont couverts cette année donc c'est
c'est votre travail c'est pas le mien et
c'est pas moi d'autant plus c'était
Julien de Normandie à cette place là
mais je veux dire c'est ça a plutôt bien
marché regardons les trous dans la
raquette il s que ça sera important
après oui la problème de moyenne
olympique on est en train on continue
d'y travailler au niveau européen après
je sais pas quel est le bon modèle quand
vous voyez là j'étais dans le pas c
c'est des gens ça fait qure fois qu'ils
ont eu des inondations en 4 ans donc
c'est quoi le bon pas de temps c'est 10
ans
c'est je m'interroge sur ce retire et
comment on fait donc on est en train de
réfléchir à autre chose avec les
services de la dgpe savoir s'il faut pas
sortir de moyen olympique ou pas et
trouver autre chose qui soit pas ça
parce Queau moyen olympique quand vous
avez 7 année sur 10 avec un un de la
grêle du gel de l'eau de la
sécheresse on va falloir faire des trucs
à 50 ans ce qui ressemble plus à rien
d'un point de vue moyenne bon donc on a
c'est on travaille à la fois sur ça avec
mes collègues européen et j'essaie de
travailler avec la dgpe sur d'autres
modèles qui permettrai d'avancer enfin
taxe foncier non bâti
ça serait une sorte de vacance une taxe
vacance quoi au sens la vacance des
biens immobiliers vous le feriez
sur enfin il faut qu'on creuse faut voir
ce que c'est quce qu' sont les effets
collatéraux le sujet alors d'abord pour
remettre une taxe après quels sont les
effets incitatifs des
incitatifs
bon comment
oui il aussi les bas à jour je dis un
mot à la sénatrice Loisier d'ailleurs on
a un sujet quand même de mise à jour
cadastrale on en a parlé l'autre jour
dans la massification forestière parce
qu'on a quand même des biens alors il y
a les biens s m mais il y a des biens
avec des mètres surtout hein l'essentiel
des surfaces forestières c'est des gens
qui ont un ou 2 hectares alors c'est le
bois de la grand-mère mais on sait pas
trop bien localiser mais on sait qu'on a
2 hectares et ça si on veut les
valoriser va falloir qu'on fasse mieux
voilà alors il nous reste encore
quelques
questions allez vous devez partir dans
combien de temps fa non faut juste que
je fasse prévenir que je vais avoir un
quart d'heure de retard mais alors
Guillin Cambier Martine Berté Bernard
bu merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre je voulais vous
interpellerer sur les dispositifs 149
dans le cadre justement du du
cofinancement du fader avec la nouvelle
avec la nouvelle pack je vais d'être
court le nouveau modèle a réduit la
dimension régionale de la mise en œuvre
de la pack les régions elles sont
désormais en charge des mesures non
surfassciques voilà tandis que l'État
lui va s'occuper de ce type de mesure ça
peut paraître un peu techno comme comme
propos mais en fait concrètement vous
vous êtes rendu encore aujourd'hui dans
dans le Pas de calis vous AZ vous avez
vu qu'on a su parfois adapter des fonds
européens c'était le cas du FEDER ça été
le cas du react youu aussi pour pouvoir
répondre à à des crises sanitaires en
particulier la difficulté de C de ce
nouvelle nouvelle réglementation fait
que justement on pourra pas adapter
notre intervention féadire régionale aux
graves inondations subies dans la région
Haut- France
nous avons su le faire par ailleurs donc
ma question c'est quelle place l'État va
laisser à chaque région pour maintenir
cette proximité avec avec la Commission
européenne en particulier d'autant plus
que la présidente a annoncé le lancement
d'un dialogue stratégique sur sur
l'avenir de l'agriculture dans launion
européenne comment est-ce qu'on
participe à ce dialogue justement sur
l'avenir et dans la perspective de la
future politique agricole commune et
comment vous pensez mobiliser et adapter
le fitadr aux réalités territoriales
comme celle que vous avez pu voir ce
matin Martine Berté
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre je vais vous parler d'une
autre impasse technique euh il s'agit et
qui impacte donc la filière des plantes
à parfum aromatiques et médicinal il
s'agit du règlement européen de juillet
2022 qui fixe des teneurs limites en
alcaloïdes pyolyidiniqu dans les
compléments alimentaires à base de
plantes ces alcaloïdes sont émis par
certaines mauvaises herbes très communes
présentes depuis toujours dans les
cultures de plantes quelques pied comme
par exemple son dans une parcelle d'un
hectare peuvent contaminer un lot de
plusieurs tonnes de plantes médicinales
sèches si on se réfère à la valeur de
400 micg par kilo qui a été fixé les
producteurs intègrent dans leur pratique
agricole de plus en plus de méthodes
alternatives elles sont encore
insuffisantes même le désherbage manuel
ne suffit pas de plus les méthodes de
dosages disponibles de ces alcaloïdes
sont imprécises et les résultats
analytiques varient selon les
laboratoires les autres pays européens
n'appliquent pas de façonussi stricte
cette réglementation donc il y a la
concurrence voilà euh donc euh ce que
souhaitent ces producteurs c'est une
période transitoire dans laquelle on
appliquerait la teneur limite de 1000
microgram par kilo qui est celle
appliquée pour le
médicament et qui permettrait pendant ce
temps donc par exemple 3 ans d'affiner
les méthodes de dosage et de calcul euh
de aussi d'évaluer l'expos des
consommateurs et des cultures et
connaître les cultures les plus à risqu
parce qu'en fait il y a peu de
consommation c'est pas comme s'il y
avait une consommation régulière donc ce
taux est beaucoup trop bas c'est
vraiment ce sont des consommations
ponctuelles de de tisane ou de
compléments alimentaires à base de
plante Bernard buit merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre je
voudrais revenir sur la prédation et sur
le comptage je pense que c'est très
important d'avoir un comptage qui soit
validé par tous parce qu'on peut pas
toutes les années avoir 3 mois après 150
200 loup de plus donc je pense qu'il
faut qu'on ait vraiment une méthode qui
soit adaptée et qui soit incontestable
et puis j'auris une question concernant
la mission d'intérêt général adaptation
au changement climatique est-ce que vous
pouvez nous apporter des précisions sur
les critères d'accès à cette
mission monieur le
ministre il y avait pas d'autes question
B il y encore qure mais je sais pas si
vous pr
les sinon je me connais sétien Noël et
Fran moner pour 30 secondes ma je
vu alors Lucien Lucien alors oui comme
mon collègue Jean-Claude Tiss je me
félicite l'augmentation des crédits
c'est une bonne nouvelle et ça tombe
bien ça fait plaisir au ministre mais ça
fait pas la
question VI de suite madame
présidente deux sujets que vous
connaissez très bien monsieur le
ministre la
lavande
donc on a voté l'an der 10 millions 5
millions étent affectés à
l'indemnisation de la campagne de 2022 1
million à la recherche qu'en est-il des
4 millions en delta bon il y a une
petite réponse à donner là-dessus
euh est-ce que vous comptez mettre en
place une aide à l'écoulement du stock
des deux années passées
puisqueeffectivement il y a un
engorgement là-dessus et je viendrai sur
le dernier sujet qui est la cerise qu'on
connaissez très bien aussi euh bon la
lutte contre la drosophile aujourd'hui
sans produit sanitaires
qui sont interdits ben c'est difficile
la solution des des filets vous le savez
c'est à moitié efficace et à moitié
satisfaisant euh le dispositif que vous
avez mis en place d'indemnisation là qui
vient d'être annoncé à la filière bon
malheureusement après les avoir
rencontrés il y a quelques jours une
cinquantaine de pourcent de de ce
résiculteur n'arrivve pas à être dans
les critères d'éligibilité donc question
est-ce que vous pensez adapter les
critères d'éligibilité et éventuellement
doter le fond un peu plus voilà
Sébastien
plat monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente écoutez monsieur le ministre
le défi de la viticulture dans certains
bassins de notre territoire n'est pas de
surmonter la crise actuelle mais
clairement d'assurer sa survie c'est le
cas vous l'avez vu chez nous dans l'ode
sur le prou méditerranéen voir au-delà
de Bordeaux à la Provence d'ailleurs le
25 si vous savez pas quoi faire une
manifestation dans l'ode
unitaire importante 25 novembre retour
viticulture non je je tra de
plaisanterie cela dit vous avez été vous
avez reçu un certain nombre de
revendication de la part des têtes de
réseau de la filière moi je voulais
avoir des précisions très très claires
sur les mesures que vous comptez mettre
en œuvre pour régler la problématique
d'abord conjoncturelle vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure du du fond d'urgence mu
entre guillemets qui qui est peut-être
pas si important que ça parce que vous
vous l'avez dit vous-même avec la
question des de minimis les entreprises
qui ont investi ces trois dernières
années qui doivent d'ailleurs faire face
au remboursement de leurs emprunts et à
l'amortissement du matériel ne pourront
pas aller sur ces fonds exceptionnels de
de financement alors qu'ils ont des
besoins de trésorerie c'est dommage mais
c'est la règle européenne on va parler
des charges sociales exonération tout ça
je pense qu'on en parlera tout à l'heure
au P FSS mais surtout j'avais besoin de
de
d'éclaircissement sur la la question et
les questions plutôt structurelles
autour notamment des demandes
d'arrachage social et sanitaire
temporaire je me pose la question de
Assier à à la la problématique de
l'installation et de la transmission
parce qu'aujourd'hui je prends un
exemple comme chez nous dans l'ode zéro
installation en vit l'année dernière et
si vous déclenchez l'arrachage
aujourd'hui ça va être 1000 exploitants
qui vont sortir du système donc un
système à mesurer donc je vrais savoir
où on an est et ensuite la question de
l' prèretraite l'accompagnement des
questions sur la prise en compte de
nouveaux zonages pour rentrer des zones
viticoles en zone in en zone défavorisée
on regarde de l'enjeu notamment de de la
protection contre risque incendie la
question de la gestion de l'eau et
surtout moi je crois beaucoup à
la à la réponse à la fois économique et
au marché pour répondre à la
problématique de de la viticulture il
faut absolument que l'on ait une
véritable diplomatie économique si on
veut les conquérir des marché à l'export
parce que on le voit la déconsommation
en France elle est là elle est elle est
énorme d'ailleurs donc il va falloir
chercher des pars de marché ailleurs on
pourra pas y aller tout seul chacun dans
notre coin voilà
merci merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre comme vous savez
les mesures de protection contre la
prédation sont prises en charge à 80 %
par
l'État sur le budget de la PAC et comme
toutes dépenses prélevées sur le budget
de la PAC le délai pour l'obtention de
ces aides peut mettre entre 6 et 12 mois
ce qui fragilise
grandement la situation financière de
certains
agriculteurs qui parfois y renonc même
donc je voudrais savoir si le PLF
prévoit par hasard un mécanisme d'avance
de
trésorerie par ailleurs s je rebondis
sur les propos qui ont été tenus juste
avant en matière de PR prédation pardon
le le compage est fondamental il y a de
nombreux départements dans lequel ce
comptage fait débat euh en haut de
Savoie le Conseil départemental a
financé un gros dispositif pour réaliser
un comptage plus fiable par le biais de
caméras thermique de pièg photographique
et de d'enregistreur Sonor et cette
expérimentation a révélé qu'on av à peu
près le double de loup sur notre
territoire que ce qui nous était annoncé
jusque-l donc je pense que le comptage
nécessite des moyens importants qui ne
doivent pas évidemment incomber au
département et je souhaiterais également
savoir si le PLF prévoit des moyens
supplémentaires pour cela je vous
remercie alors dernière petite question
Franck Montauger merci madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le ministre
dans le prolongement des des propos de
Sébastien
plat une parole prononcé il y aelqu
quelques jours par quelqu'un que vous
connaissez Vincent Piquemal qui pour la
3è année consécutive a été touché par
des phénomènes climatiques en
l'occurrence le Milot après avoir eu le
gel et la grêle sur TR années
successives donc les assurances ne
marchent pas la moyenne olympique est
est en ce qu'elle est ils sont à
l'agonie on a des exploitations
installées de longues dates qui sont à
deux doigts de déposer le bilan c'est
absolument dramatique donc il il demande
des des des mesures d'urgence de de de
notamment auprès des assureurs à titre à
titre commercial des gestes commerciaux
pour les aider à continuer à respirer et
et moi je me pose la question monsieur
le ministre c'est la la la la demande
que je que je vous fais l'État dans des
circonstances dramatique comme celle-là
ne pourrait-il pas
diligenter des des structures de soutien
d'urgence un peu à l'instar de ce qui se
fait pour les entreprises via les
codéfis vous savez les les les les
comités département t de d'aide au
financement des agricultures des des
entreprises en difficulté voilà je pense
qu'il y a quelque chose à inventer il y
a a il y a des drames aussi humains qui
qui sont en train de se nouer par
rapport à ça au-delà de la de la
dimension économique du sujet voilà ce
sont des gens qui qui qui qui produisent
des choses de qualité du vin de qualité
certains sont en bio ou en ou en HVE ont
fait les efforts pour et c'est encore
plus pénalisant pour ceux qui sont en en
bio ou ou en en HVE que de vivre ces
situation là voilà donc je je voulais
vous faire cette proposition monsieur
ministre madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs alors d'abord
sur la nouvelle programmation fader
alors ça méritera qu'on prolonge parce
que je fais bref mais l'essentiel des
mesures non surfaques sont resté au
région donc les capacités d'adaptation y
compris pour l'investissement restent
valable donc je vrais voir où ça va
bloquer en fait que ce qui a été
transféré à l'état c'est les ma on en a
parlé enfin il y a aucune capacité
d'adaptation des Maes compris quand il y
a des inondations donc je je je suis
preneur que on puisse je dis à mes
équipes éventuellement pourre contact
avec vous parce que je vois pas là je
vois bien le débat mais je vois pas là
où il y aurait une difficulté me
semble-t-il sur sur cette question là
mais ça vaut le coup et d'ailleurs je
vais faire appel aux régions dans le
cadre du fader pour accompagner le
soutien aux
agriculteurs donc je je pense que la
souplesse de ce point de vue-l il y en a
peut-être d'autres qu'il faut regarder
mais cl mais je propose queon puisse en
rééchanger pour que je comprenne là pour
y avoir un un Boquet euh sur la question
des des impasses techniques madame la
sénatrice nous avons regardé de près le
sujet mais alors c'est vrai qu'il y a un
sujet d'impasse donc on est en train de
regarder avec mes équipes et et les
services c'est le c'est la PI des
situations quand on est dans ces
situations là sujets qui sont un peu
récurrents sur et compris les plantes
aromatiques ou autres donc ce que je
vous propose c'est que nous on va on va
regarder avec les les producteurs sur
cette question là de regarder ce que
sont les dérogations qu'on peut qu'on
peut avoir là où on peut le faire
j'ajoute qu'il a eu des bonnes nouvelles
parce que sur rich on est plutôt sur
enfin ce qui était l'équivalent de la
directive rich la réglementation rich on
a plutôt quelque chose qui correspond je
pense à la lavande à ce qui était qui
relève complètement les craintes que
pouvit avoir la filière mais évidemment
c'est un sujet sur lequel il faut être
vigilant sur la question de la prédation
ça me permettra de répondre au sénateur
Bru et à la sénatrice Noël qui m' on
parlé tous les deux oui la question du
comptage c'est d'ailleurs pardon un des
éléments madame la présid idente je sais
que vous y êtes sensible il faut qu'on
ait un comptage qui il y a deux choses
sur le comptage faut qu'il soit
scientifiquement crédible de partager
c'estàdire que il y ait pas de défiance
sur le comptage or depuis le début sur
le loup il y a une défiance sur le
comptage c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu
cette expérimentation dans votre
département d'ailleurs euh bon il faut
qu'on trouve un point d'atterrissage
deuxième élément faut pas que j'ai un
comptage provisoire en mai et définitif
en août qui m'explique qu'on s'est
trompé de
300 non mais on peut se tromper
d'ailleurs mais ça peut arriver de se
tromper hein ça fait 2 heur de la f vu
entre le début du mois de juillet et
septembre j'ai j'ai mes heures de
bienveillance mais il faut qu'on ait
quelque chose qui soit crédible quoi et
je veux mettre personne en cause parce
que je pense qu' faut qu'on essaie de
c'est pas du tout ce que vous avez fait
mais faut qu'on essaie de crédibiliser
une démarche où on se mette d'accord
quoi de je veux qu'on ait un comptage t
en saison pour pas qu'on me dise tiens
j'ai j'ai oublié de te dire Marc il y en
a 50 de plus à faire mais il y a plus
que de mois alors bon courage hein tout
ça c'est c'est un peu énervant y compris
pour le ministre de l'Agriculture en
fait c'est pour ça que j'ai mis la
pression sur les préfets un
peu correctement come on va dire mais à
un moment on est en débours de 40 cette
année on est en débours de 40 de l'an
dernier ça fait 80 80 ça fait des petits
on va jamais arriver à réguler avec avec
ça not affaire alors je sais que c'est
pas une régulation mais enfin quand même
il y a il a il y a et et à mon avis ça
ça permettra de donc le comptage est un
élément important il me semble oui alors
on a un sujet vous avez raison sur le
sujet de l'indemnisation on est en train
de regarder comment on peut faire des
accomtes pour libérer plus vite ça peut
pas être des accomtes nationaux parf
bref je rentre pas dans la mécanique
Fond Européen pour le coup elle est un
peu compliquée pour cet objet là mais
j'ai bien identifié alors pour le coup
j'ai pas encore réussi je le dis très
sincèrement devant vous ça fait un an
que je dis il faut qu'on trouve un
système où on paye plus vite que 6 à 12
mois parce que les bergers plus les
barrières plus les clôture ça coûte très
vite très cher et c'est très vite
beaucoup d'argent qui est dehors plus
c'est pas tout donc on est en train de
regarder un système d'avance plus un
logiciel qui avait normalement comme
tous lesiciel devait simplifier la vie
des éleveurs s'appelle sa Fran je crois
celui-là et en fait il est pire
maisos Osiris c'est quand même plus non
non monsieur sénateur vous êtes dur avec
Osiris mais celui-là il est plus
compliqué bon on va se le dire il vaut
mieux je me suis fait présenter
d'ailleurs par les services de l'État
qui sont eu mêm lucides le dispositif
quand j'étais dans les Aes deprence bon
bref j'ai demandé des simplifications et
des développements nouveaux pour que
j'ai c'est pas possible d'avoir à chaque
parcelle de remplir 25 fois la même
chose c'est assez désespérant surtout
pour être payé 6 à 8 mois donc on a un
sujet de délai et un sujet de
simplification pour le coup et ça j'
person parce que ça c'est un sujet
désespérant j'en finis avec les sujets
bon la vente cerise enfin
ctait9 il en reste quatre parce que ça
pas été consommé j'ai dit déjà qu'on
pourrait travailler avec la filière on
est en train d'y travailler monsie
sénateur donc c'est pas un sujet en soi
c'est9 plus 1 je je j'insiste sur le
programme de recherche faut pas qu'on
vien me dire dans un an ou deux on a pas
avancé sur les questions de recherche on
n pas les alternatives hein parce que je
préfère qu'on vient me dire on a cherché
on l'a pas trouvé plutôt qu'on AA pas
cherché pour être très clair et là c'est
un objet comment ne pas chercher pour
être s de trouver oui c'est ça il faut
chercher pour essayer de se donner une
chance de trouver parce que
sinon les interdictions produisent pas
les solutions mais la l'absence de
recherche ne produit pas non plus de
solution donc il faut faire les deux ni
l'un ni l'autre pardon 3è élément sur la
serise moi je je veux bien qu'on voit
les critères on a baissé le taux de
spécialisation à 25 % ce qui est rien
c'est un des plus bas qu'on a fait de on
a une perte de chiffre d'affaires de 20
% ce qui est pas grand-chose il y a un
moment voyez ce que je veux dire donc on
va regarder documenter moi je veux bien
mais c'est été vu par ailleurs je le dis
très simplement avec la filière he voilà
on peut on peut s'être tromper
collectivement là aussi j'accepte ça
mais quand même je dis ça sous l'œil on
a fait un truc sérieux on a abaissé les
seils le plus possible dans le cadre de
ce qui ne serait pas une surcompensation
parce qu'il faut être vigilant à ça il y
a un moment si on a perdu moins de 20 %
et qu'on est à plus de 25 % de
spécialisation c'est pas une perte de
nature suffisante pour justifier du net
comprenez j'ai des agriculteurs en VTI
ou autre qui perdent 40 50 80 % là oui
là on a des seuils qui sont bas quel que
soit le critère sur lequel on perèd il
me semble mais regardons si ça va pas
mais enfin là il me semble que ça serait
un peu à désespérer je sais pas si c'est
Bill en cours mais à nous désespérer
collectivement et puis je finis sur les
questions euh viticol alors d'abord
monsieur le sénateur montoger vous avez
raison il y a beaucoup de désespérance
ça m'amène au point initial que j'ai dit
c'est si on n'est pas fichu de mettre
ces exploitations dans une trajectoire
de résilience de transition elles sont
par construction les les victimes
avancées dans des départements comme les
vtres du dérèglement climatique et de et
du changement climatique donc si je leur
dis c'est vous avez pas dit d'ailleurs
on est d'accord làdessus j'ai m tenu le
même propos ouis non mais je sais qu'on
est d'accord attendez non non mais je
sais qu'on est d'accord mais il faut
leur parler des deux oui deuxième
élément on est outillé on a fait des
fonds d'urgence on essaie de regarder
moi ce que je propose c'est d'essayer de
regarder dans ces départements là qu'on
fasse à la fois le c'est quoi dans 5 ou
10 ans y compris en aant
l'investissement la transition il faut
leur faire le paquet global parce que
tous les ans remettre du fond d'urgence
en fait on en perd au fur et à mesure ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas regarder ça
veut pas non mais je sais qu'on partage
mais je le redis je veux dire il faut en
revanche qu'on regarde dans des
département comme ça il faut qu'on le
fasse dans lesé Ros dans l'autre dans
les Pyrénées Orientales parce que là on
est dans des situations d'impasse c'est
pas la question de remettre tous les ans
20 millions parce qu'on les mettra ça
c'est en fait en fait ça ne ça ne tient
pas les exploitations et après il faut
qu'on ait un système où tout le monde se
met autour de la table la banque
l'assureur voilà nous les collectivités
en disant on est avec vous et très vite
comment et très très vite et vite je
sais alors après c'est les mécanismes
oui je
sais je suis dans oui c'est ce qu'on
fait parfois dans certains départements
je ce qu'on fait quand il y a des
grosses crises le problème c'est que
c'est des crises récurrentes et qui qui
épouon tout le monde en plus ceuxl ils
ont peut-être eu de la grippe aviaère
ils ont peut-être eu enfin bref ils ont
l'éleveur que j'ai été voir dans le
département dans votre département il
avait eu gripe avière et mou à 95
culture parce que les systèmes et alors
le paradoxe c'est qu'on va réclamer
plutôt à ce qu'il y a des systèmes plus
diversifiés pour couvrir le risque et
c'est ceux-là qui sont les plus en
risque
aujourd'hui c'est ceux-là qui sont les
plus en difficulté donc je regarde après
l'UR je comme vous le voyez j'essaie
plutôt de me démener dans la question
d'urgence alors après je je fais dans
des délais qui sont quand même des
délais où il faut qu'on puisse
documenter la perte faut qu'on regarde
si je vais pas me faire shooter pardon
du terme au niveau européen parce que
j'enfrain des règles que je surcompense
pas et les règles des minimist sont font
partie des des risques qu'on peut avoir
dans la durée si je peux me permettre
les assureurs ont intérêt à jouer je oui
ils ont intérêt à organiser la
résilience per ben évidemment parce que
dans le système économique ils ont
intérêt aussi voilà fait passer mess
c'est passé en tout cas tout cas au nom
de tous nos collègues vraiment un très
grand merci Monsieur le Ministre parce
que vous nous avez consacré énormément
de temps vous avez été très précis et
détaillé dans l'ensemble de vos réponses
et puis on vous donne rendez-vous bah
sur le débat sur le PLF je crois que ça
sera le vendredi 8 décembre la mission
agriculture je crois à peu près vous me
la prenez mais c'est très bien en tout
cas j'y serai
normalement